Call Hiyoooo Allllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllll
too much to the right? Should I move over? I feel like I should move over.
Nah, maybe I'll walk too much up the screen.
I'll make myself bigger.
I'll make myself bigger. Why do I have two of these open?
One of these has to go.
One of these things is not like the other.
One of these things made me lose tracking.
Wow, I had everything so ready some pie and now I'm being a klutz.
It's like you can still hear my voice.
Okay, anyways, whoa, whoa, whoa, welcome senpai. Welcome to the screen. Welcome to Deathmark again.
I have good news. My rash has gone so much down, got down so much.
Yesterday I was like, it looks like my arm again and not some and not like him.
Let me grab my controller. I'm so not ready for this.
What happened and how? I don't know. I literally, I think it was my bed sheets.
I put them in the wash and then I put them back onto my bed and then like overnight it got like X,
like super better. I was like, thank you.
But I'm so happy. Oh, and thank you Griffith for the 10 members. I hope everyone enjoys the memberships.
Evil bed sheets, right? How long did you have those bed sheets?
Oh, five, half a year now.
Did stress play a role in your rash? Probably, 100% probably.
Like it's, I don't know, maybe, maybe I like went to bed with, I don't know, something or maybe
mama, mama or papa was cleaning up in there and they had like, I don't know, stuff on them.
Who knows? How often do you wash them? Washing? What does that mean?
I don't know.
Forget about it. Forget about it. You don't need to wash shades?
I learned my lesson. No worry. Let me move over here a little bit. Yeah, we go.
Oh, but like those are actually new bed sheets. I don't know what happened, but they were new and I've been like using them for
um, like maybe, maybe a few months, like half a year now and nothing happened. And then suddenly I was just like, oh, I'm allergic.
And then, oh, so today I walked around the, I walked around the neighborhood and then I had, I had a thought, the, does, does
senpai's play ping pong because I'm palm?
Question, is that the reason?
It is now.
I withhold my answer. Oh, senpai's naughty.
Kohai, what did you have for dinner today? I had a ham and cheese sandwich.
This morning I had pho.
I didn't see anything. You didn't play anything at all. Oh, yeah, not anything at all. Not that I see the paddles everywhere or the nets hidden under one of your beds.
I know everything I see. Oh, this, my, this bang hides my third eye. That hides the Gigan eye.
What bed? The doggie bed! The doggie bed in the haze!
You get doggie beds. I put a little stuffed animal in there. It's a little pillow.
Excuse me. It's starting to get really cold, so I'm being affected by the weather.
But um, as a warning though, my arm still heats up even though the rash is like pretty much like really,
it's still like 40% still there. Tea check?
Today's tea is pomegranate green tea. I wanted to stay awake for senpai's.
We would never lie to our precious Kohai.
Says a liar.
Word of the day, um, contingency. Like a plan. Like, what you,
what senpai's need? A contingency plan.
Okay, let's talk to the people.
Also, I'm sorry. I'm sorry about yesterday. I put the days wrong.
Do you know what mama and papa always say to me?
They always go, merci! You're so clumsy. Clumsy, clumsy, clumsy.
Mama, mama always gets mad at me.
Because when I have a button-up shirt or like a cardigan, I always miss one button. So the,
so it's like, the buttons are always wrong.
So I was like, oh, so when I told them like, yeah, I made the days wrong. So I have to go down and
tell, tell everyone that, that it's the wrong day. They're like, of course, of course you did.
I spent the day looking for a matching alchemy model, kid. Oh,
is the senpai's want to have a matching alchemy model?
Yeah, it's, it's, it's a really, it's really fast. I built it in like,
maybe 10 minutes, maybe less than that, five minutes. I suffered the one time where I made a
mistake and then I had to poke, poke one in the mouth again because I forgot to put the strawberry in.
But I really like alchemy. It was like my first, when I was playing Pokemon
Sword and Shield. Oh, which one do I have? I think I have Shield. Yeah. Um,
oh, when I have Sword and, Sword and Shield, it was the first Gigantamax Pokemon I got.
So I was like, yeah.
What's your favorite alchemy variation? The original one, because that's the one I got.
My alchemy is named Milfyu after the Galaxy Angel character. If you know Galaxy Angel.
The key to the spirit's grudge. It should be within each elementary. Oh, sorry, I was supposed to do voices.
It should be within each elementary. Fate has tied him to that school. However, even I do not
know what form it will take.
My favorite Pokemon is Mimikyu.
Mimikyu is a, is a dangerous Pokemon. I really liked Galaxy Angel because it was the first
DVD I ever had for like an anime series.
Hey, wait, Mashita appears as we're getting ready to leave. Bad news.
Oh, my favorite Pokemon used to be Vaporeon until, until the copy pasta. And then I, I had a less
respect. I had a less liking to Vaporeon.
But I, I can tell you mama and papa's favorite Pokemon, mama's favorite Pokemon is a Lapras.
Which I, I don't know about you senpai, but I feel like Lapras is a very mommy Pokemon.
So when she chose that, I was like, oh, somehow this is so, this is very suitable for you,
mommy. And papa and my sister's favorite is Snorlax.
But yeah, when mama, mama picked Lapras, I was like,
ah, this is, this is like a very, this is very suitable for mama.
But like, they also really like Pikachu. I think that's the only one they actually know the name of.
It's the only one they actually know the name of. But like, if I gave them like a picture of like
Pokemons, mama picked out Lapras and she was like, yeah, this one's my favorite.
And papa picked out Snorlax and my sister also was like, I like Snorlax.
Imagine if papa chose Vaporeon.
Even if he did, I would not tell senpais. I would not tell senpais, but he did it.
That high school girl. It's Molly, it's gone.
Damn.
At least she's nowhere in the mansion.
Speaking of which, I didn't see her when we were talking to Mary in the hall either.
Maybe she ran away. That doesn't make sense.
What would she accomplish by doing that?
Running away from the mansion won't make her mark disappear.
It could be her form of escape. Many kill themselves if they know they're gonna die.
Okay, okay, Mr. Detective Guy.
I maybe something happened to her like the spirit's curse.
Molly saw Hannah Hickel in the mirror at the school. So she's the mark bearer with the strongest
connection. It's possible that he zeroed in on her just like Tsukasa said. But there's nothing we can do.
Let's get ready to go. Yeah, we really can't do anything right now.
Even if something happened to Molly, if we can get the mark to vanish, I should save her too.
Let's head out. We're going back to H Elementary.
Let's go back, senpai. Back to the beginning. Does anyone get that reference? Come on.
Yeah, yeah, this is your mom movie. You come back to H Elementary.
Senpais are so smart. I'm so proud of Senpai.
I knew for a while that in the end this place is just a school.
Well, an abandoned school with a monster in it. And you know, the security card probably just died.
Oh yeah, and there's like killer plants in there. Oh, and a bunch of poisonous snakes. So not exactly normal.
Let's go. Tsukasa nods silently and steps forward.
Wait, did I go with the kid?
Oh yeah, I went with the kid because I was like, oh well, adults, they'll fucking die, right?
Okay, let's go in.
Okay, let's see. Examine.
Anything new? What's in the shoe locker? The battered shoe rack is covered in dirt.
Okay, disintegrated stuff. Okay, okay. I want to go to the left this time.
We saw it earlier, but look at all these flowers. Roses are red, violets are blue.
We saw it. The hallway has completely transformed. Seeing them like this.
Are roses on that pretty? When you look close, they're scary.
Huh? Uh-huh. What's that?
Tsukasa suddenly speaks up. There.
By the window. Hey, over there, something's sparkling.
The window? I see her rose vines. I may as well check it out though.
Oh, there it is. Something's glinting over by the window.
Looks like something's buried in the rose vines. It's definitely something there.
Sorry, I'm coughing.
I didn't notice it before. No, maybe it wasn't there yet when we passed through here earlier.
A guard from before. Did he drop that? Maybe. He might have fallen on the floor and been
lifted up by the vines. It's only now that it's high enough to be spotted.
If it belonged to the guard, then it could come in handy while we're investigating.
He's in charge of watching this building after all. Let's check it out.
Feel it. Oh, what if I cut myself though? I pushed my fingers into the vines. Ow!
I was careful, but oddly shaped thorns still cut my skin.
Damn, this is a pain. I keep fighting with the vines. I finally reached the metal object.
Got school curing! Yeah, make sure to hydrate. Okay. It is a little cold here, Senpai.
So, I might, I might be coughing because it's cold. It's been raining a lot.
Yep, just as we thought. These definitely belong to the guards.
These would be extremely useful. You can get into places we...
The castle suddenly cuts off mid-sentence. What's wrong?
Nothing. I just forgot what I was saying. Anyway, let's keep looking around.
Need info was added to spirit file. Continued investigation of the school.
Huh.
Maybe... I know that the kid doesn't like an adult, but I feel so uncomfortable bringing your kid around.
You know? I feel so uncomfortable bringing a tiny tot.
A tiny tot around with me. Maybe I should go back and grab the guy?
I'm gonna go back and grab the guy.
Maybe he should stay with the creepy doll girl.
I don't know. I'm just like...
Also, you know, kids are very... I don't know. I feel like the detective might have a gun,
and that might come in handy. But also... Yeah, you know what? I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back.
I'm gonna go back.
Don't fucking do that. Don't fucking do that, gay. I hate kids.
I mean, kid's laughter. Stranny!
Eyeball. Let's take...
Stranny raid! Welcome, Stranny! Welcome to the stream! Welcome raiders! How was...
the hat game... link... the hat game? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
I was watching a bit of it, and I was like, oh, it's so cute!
Turns out, I'm MLG on Zelda and did the boss first time. Nice!
Well, welcome, everyone. Today, I am playing Deathmark.
It's a visual novel, horror-ish game with quick time events and
choices and some movements. So, if you like this,
let's play.
Okay, now we'll return to HLM entry, because I'm just like, I don't know! I don't like bringing a kid
with me! There you go. Spooky spooky. Okay, all in favor to go left? I'm going left.
Okay, I use the school key ring and open the door. Yeah! Son of a bitch!
This is why we're like, I don't like kids, generally.
Did that get a senpai's? Child jumpscare.
Did that get senpai's too? Because my heart dropped for a second.
Okay, let's, uh, look.
The aluminum chalk case has dents all over it, as if something hit it.
Eel. Something's inside the chalk case.
Found a worn-out talisman, and I pick up the worn-out talisman. I feel warmth flow through me!
My heart died for a moment. I got used to it. I was like, ah, I forgot the jump scares.
Got soap power. Yeah, the worn-out talisman crumbles silently in my hand.
Let's check out this really dirty aquarium.
Look, and glass is terribly stained, making it impossible to see inside.
I touch it. I hesitantly stick my hand in the tank. When I do, my fingers touch something cold.
There's water left inside. Just water. For some reason, Mashita looks disappointed.
Of course. There's enough water left inside that I could scoop it up if I had a container.
I do have a container!
I do have a container! I have... this plastic bottle! Yeah!
I take the plastic bottle out and put it in the tank. It gurgles as it fills with water.
Got bottle of water.
Or, as some people say, oh!
What are you gonna do with it? I don't know! I want it! Why? If I can use it, I want it!
Okay, let's look. When you open an umbrella in a typhoon, it will break because the wind's too strong.
So first, I tried to put holes in an umbrella. The way... that way, it wouldn't break a strong wind.
And who would those people be? Hmm?
The British.
Oh my gosh! Okay, I think I need to put on a sweater, Senpai.
I think I need to put on a sweater, Senpai.
British jumpscare. A bit too chilly. Yeah, it's super cold!
I think that's why I'm coughing a lot.
I think that's why I'm coughing a lot because I'm gonna wear this cardigan.
Yeah, I always have a cardigan with me.
And... Blake it up!
It's super hot here. If I had to choose between hot versus cold, I would choose cold.
I can be under many layers, but I cannot strip more.
Okay, I cannot remove the skin.
I don't know why.
Um, Stroni was wearing a sweater and nothing else.
Oh my!
Who let you remove our skin, Kohei? Really? You'd let me do that?
You would let... you'd let me do that, Senpai? You let me tear your skin off?
No, when using it, put a plastic sheet on it to transform it into an extra strong umbrella.
A strengthened umbrella protects from thorns or branches blown by the wind.
Okay, if I... that's a hint. Yes, that's how kids think.
He acts like he was never a kid himself.
What? No, it's nothing.
Anything else here? We looked there.
I think we already looked here.
Uh, did we?
Anything else? Sparkle.
Now, okay, we're good. Let's get out of here.
Oh my gosh, I misaligned the buttons again!
Okay, there I go.
Okay.
We already went there, it looks like, I think.
Okay, move forward!
The broken window is letting in piercing cold wind. Okay.
What's that?
The rain coming in from the broken window is making the floor cold and damp.
Are we at the end of the hall? I found you, kid!
Fucking kids.
Climb the stairs.
Anything around here?
Pieces of concrete litter the floor. I think they came from the walls.
Ah, that's why it's cold. Yeah, climb the stairs.
Plies in the snakes cover the hallway. I'd be foolish to keep going.
I decided to go back to the landing. Okay, let's go back down then. Let's go back down.
Can we go in here already? I don't know if we can go in here already.
Oh yeah, we did. We're out of here. I explored the heck out of that place.
How many snakes do you need to cover a staircase? A lot!
For one really big one. Wait, go back.
Did I ever look at this?
Look, the light on alarm is very faint. Something might be wrong with it.
I open up and shine the flashlight to see if there's anything inside.
Found a worn-out talisman. When I picked up the worn-out talisman, I feel warmth flow through me.
Got soul power.
The worn-out talisman crumbles silently in my hand.
There we go. What is soul power for?
Give me a moment, Senpai.
When you do quick time events and you do the wrong,
in each moment, you lose a soul power. So when you lose soul power and it hits zero, you die.
So these worn-out talismans look like they recover that.
Did I go in here already? Yeah, I already went in here.
So help, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, Senpai. Yeah, you're so smart, Senpai.
I don't think we went into this room. Use the school key ring and open the door.
I move to step into the classroom.
And suddenly there's a strong grip on my shoulder.
I glance at the hallway out of the corner of my eye.
I'm pretty sure Mashita was on my other side.
No, even if they were on this side, they would have no reason to grab me.
Ah, here it is! Senpai, live or die.
Calm down, I'm just imagining things. My voice doesn't sound very convincing.
Don't panic, it's an illusion. Calm down, hold it together.
And I see Chou enveloped my right side.
I have 3,000 soul power, something's gripping my shoulder.
Oh.
Is that you? Is that you, Mashita?
I turn Mashita and open my mouth to tell them.
One, two, ah!
Safe.
I see a terrifying face in the darkness. Yeah, kids are pretty terrifying, huh?
Kids are terrifying creatures.
And then an outline laying in wait for me.
Oh no, oh no, oh no, what should I do? What should I do?
Uh, I'mma close my eyes! Fuck, close my eyes! Fuck!
Go light, go light!
Excuse my eyes, shut and pray.
Safe! Oh yeah! I knew it, if I, I knew it, I knew, I knew if I said something I'm probably gonna
die because this kid hates adults, right? This ghost kid hates adults. So if they hear a deep
voice they'll be like, oh my gosh, it's an adult, die! Just then. Hey, what's wrong?
With Mashita's voice, the figure vanishes. I find myself standing in front of the door.
Survive. Woo!
The mark burns scarlet. Dawn, half an hour left until death closes in.
We are gonna disregard time because I'm gonna spend a few more hours playing.
You okay? Yeah!
Mashita picked something off my left shoulder. This is...
The hand I felt gripping my shoulder was actually a rose thorn.
But more importantly, Mashita, what's the matter? You're acting kind of... acting kind of what?
Something's wrong, he's not acting normal.
Amnesia, my heart pangs with worry. Is Mashita spacing out because the mark's curse has progressed?
But I don't understand. I'm still the same, at least as far as I know.
Come on, hurt right. Mashita shuffles forward like a zombie. Something is seriously wrong.
Bad. Danger kept on us so quickly for running out of time. This condition might get worse.
I'll figure something out.
Okay, here we go. What's that? A white powder substance scattered around. Look.
A coarse powder, a glitters in the glow of the flashlight. Is it, is it cocaine?
I'm not really inclined to sticking it in my mouth to make sure, but it's probably so. Oh, okay.
Okay, it's salt. If I had a container, I'd take some with me. I do have a container. I have...
Ball water. My powder seems to be salt. Take out the bottle of water and fill it with powder.
Oh, it's salt water.
First purify with sea water. Yeah. I hear that voice again. Sea water. So that would be salt water, then?
Oh, hi. I can't read Japanese. What does this say?
Hey, hey. Oh, that's a lot of words I can't read. I can't read.
The plants are dry and withered.
Say, say, I can't read. I can't read.
Knee, knee, no, no.
Something about your car is extended warranty, probably.
Then say, could I? Oh, I hate teacher. Fair.
Fair.
I hate sensei. Got it. There are six office ladies who ride my train. I observed them for 10 days.
So true. When I was a kid, I was like, I don't like my teachers.
I learned popular colors are brown and pink. Everyone's hair is brown and their mouths are pink.
Feel it. Paper is falling apart. Got anyone who would care if I tore it off and took it with me.
Wait, I can take these?
I need to go back to the other room. I totally needed to grab those things.
Look. Experiment. I poured different liquids on the weed in my yard to see which was effective.
Results?
C. Miso soup and D. Salt water work. Conclusion. Salt can destroy weeds.
Solving salt in water first makes it easier for the plants to absorb and speed the effects.
Understood.
We'll take that as well. These are hints. We're going to go back and grab the other stuff.
Miso soup, yeah. Anything else? Oh, there's something on the ceiling.
Does the roof have a leak? The ceiling looks stained in places.
Anything else? I'm having this plant thing.
Oops. I didn't mean to do that.
I'm going to go back.
I'm going to go back because clearly we needed that one thing.
I'm going to grab those hints I saw.
Is it this one? Yeah, it was this one. I'm going to grab them.
Eel. Yeah, take it. Take it. Take it. Take it.
Miso has a lot of sodium. Oh, yeah, that's true. I like Miso soup. I like the kelp one.
I plan to strengthen weeds. I'm going to take this one, too.
I'm going to take that one, too. Thank you.
Umbrella that withstands typhoon.
We didn't find an umbrella before, did we? Oh, wait, hold on. It's a bed and desk. Look.
Yes, you'll find it at any other school. What's surprising? It doesn't look very weathered.
So that goes to show how durable school desks are.
Deal it. Stick my hand inside and feel around. Something pokes my finger. I grab it and pull
it out. Is it the umbrella thing? Yeah! What's it doing here? I have an idea. This umbrella might
have been part of the display for the independent research we found earlier.
Oh, though, what's the point? I'm going to use it.
I see the nicely folded dark plastic sheet amongst the garbage. Take it, too.
Their blood denies them. Denies them. Put it together and what have you got?
That conscious thought, I start speaking. Blood denies them. Does that mean repel with blood?
I pop open the wire umbrella and I spread the plastic sheet over it.
Huh, just like it says in the research paper, you can create something like an umbrella.
But it's not fast and dawn. It'll be impossible to carry it around like this.
But we'll have to hold it together to use it. Thankfully, there are two of us here. One person
to open the umbrella first and one person to spread the sheet. If you manage to combo like that,
we can use the blood stain sheet as an umbrella. Sorry to make you wait.
Right. Ashita gives a big reply. I'm sure it'll come in handy.
I feel like everything is here for a reason. New info was added to the spirit file. Blood stain,
umbrella. Okay, okay. We found the umbrella. I was like, okay, clearly we have something.
Uh, let's turn back and head this away. Where was I before? I think I was close to the end, right?
Anything else here? No more ugly kids? I don't think I have this ever open. Fire doors,
rested shut and won't move. Okay, that's probably useless then.
Climb the stairs.
Halfway up the stairs, I chip on something. What's this?
Moe's bag is on the staircase.
Got Moe's bag. Inside the bag is some random junk along with her school jacket.
If it's here, that means...
Is Moe still in the school?
But a cracked mirror is the only thing in sight.
If it's counting her bag, there's no trace of Moe anywhere.
In any case, we'll just have to keep looking around.
Isn't I looking now?
Look, it's a crack. There's cracks in the mirror. There's nothing else particularly odd about it.
Ew, my finger down the cracks. Mash it to watch as me wordly, but nothing happens.
Going to go up now?
Climb the stairs. I think we grabbed everything.
Twice in a snake's cover the hallway. Be foolish to try to keep going.
All right, we decide to go back to the landing.
Okay, well, anything else?
Well, do we have her bag? Oops.
Went down the stairs.
Am I missing something?
The broken window is letting piercingly cold air in.
Okay, hold on. Well, we're going to explore some more.
Part of these motherfucking snakes in my motherfucking school.
Okay, I think we checked everything here. We got the salt.
I was hoping to use the salt on it, but I guess I don't need it.
I don't think I need it.
My tonight is, I think, everything in this room.
The dust is so thick on the ceiling that just walking around causes showers of particles.
That's unsafe and unsanitary. I wonder this school is abandoned.
Anything around here?
Ceiling is filthy and the fluorescent lights are broken.
Wait, warning and contacts. Fire-containing warnings and list of contacts.
Do not leave handprints on the mirror in the eastern stairway.
Thank you, Independent Research Presentation, First Floor,
Multi-Purpose Classroom. Come check it out.
Independent Research, huh? Okay.
Uh, deal?
Don't find anything in particular.
Okay.
Mercy, can I say how attractive you are? Sempais loves you. Mwah!
And I love you, Sempai. Mwah!
I swear I went through everything. Did I not go through everything?
Okay, hold on.
What does this say? I can't read this either.
There's nonsensical scribbles on the blackboard.
The dust is so thick. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, same thing.
Okay, so we're going to assume everything on the ceiling.
Can you do anything with Moe's bag? Here, let me check my bag first.
Oh, I can power Intelligence 11.
Okay, Dexterity 11, Dexterity 6.
What's this? Oh, that's the spirit file.
I have a flare, plastic sheet, school key ring,
a food umbrella, wire umbrella, Moe's bag.
Some textbooks and items of unknown purposes.
Oh, she's in the school! Somewhere, right?
Okay, she might be in that room again.
A wall near the window is burnt. There must have been a fire here a long time ago.
And the door in left the staff room. In here?
Open the glass door and check inside, but there isn't anything that catches my eye.
There's an entrance to the underground room. Go to the underground room.
Shall we go in there again? Yeah.
Is there anything else in here?
Right up corpse. Look, body is twisted in odd position as if still in pain even now.
Heal it, hesitantly search the corpse, but I don't find anything.
Okay, well, the bad room. Yeah, the bad room full of stuff that happened badly.
I'm checking through all of them, though.
Look, body is twisted in odd position, blah, blah, blah. Okay, touch it.
Okay, find anything about you. Touch it.
Okay, we got something. I hesitantly searched the corpse.
Something flashes within the vine by its feet. Got round hand mirror. Like a gift for a young woman.
Mark has died in deep crimson. A few minutes left until death closes in.
Shit! A loud noise suddenly rings out.
A terrible pain runs through my wrist. It feels like something's biting into my bone.
Ashita? Hey, are you listening? Yeah, I can hear you.
At least he's still replying to me. So, what the way he's acting is.
Can't keep going like this. Move, come on.
Shout rings through the building. New info was added to spirit file. Last hand.
Am I gonna fucking die now?
Oh well. R.I.P.
I'm getting, I'm guessing that's the titular death mark? Yeah.
Instant I step into the hallway. A strange, indescribable feeling hits me.
Like a solid presence is closing in on me from deep within the darkness.
A router appears out of nowhere. And it runs down the hallway. I thought that was it,
but it stopped the part way. Grim's back is left to see what we're doing.
Hey, wait up. I grabbed Ashita's wrist and chased after it.
We chase after the rabbit and we arrive at eastern staircase.
We quickly climb up the stairs and stand in front of the mirror.
Heard it. I look around for the creature.
Just then, red drops of something fall from above.
Scarlet rose petals.
I slowly raise my eyes up to the ceiling.
The instant I see that, I let out a groan.
Okay, over fine. It's fine.
It's heavily weighted with both fear and relief.
Snippets, don't look!
Moe is up there, hanging from rose vines.
It's her. He points at her, strangely amused.
But she's not the only one up there.
It's a corpse hiding in the vines, too. It looks like the guard.
Suddenly, the vines snap like the weight is too much.
Moe crashes painfully up to the ground.
Hey, hang in there!
Yeah. I quickly glance over her to make sure she's not hurt.
The mark is obvious. It's swollen, pulsing, red like a giant.
Like a large, dangerous-looking pomegranate.
It looks like it progressed a lot further than the mark on my wrist.
See, so this is why.
Did she get desperate and come to the school to try to do something?
She did run away.
In any case, I need to get some clothes on her.
Take the jacket out of her bag and slide her arm into a sleeve.
She's still pretty out of it, but she manages to get a rest on by herself.
Huh? Oh, it's you, mister! Why?
The mark's progression must be affecting her, just like Mashita.
I doubt anything that I would say will make sense to her.
Besides, right now...
He's here.
And uh, Niko is.
I know, but what should I do? What am I supposed to do?
There's nowhere to hide.
I look at Moe and Mashita, their eyes are unfocused.
We'll die here. We'll all die here.
I'm the only one who might have a chance of overturning that fate.
Gaining the key and letting the grudge befall me by to survive.
You'll be required to be callous to make the escape of the spirit appear.
The way to repel the spirit hides within its grudge.
Mary's words echo in my head.
I open my bag and look through everything I picked up throughout the school.
It's one of these, the key, but it all looks like junk!
I'm not sure if I'm going to be able to get through this.
Garbage is all I have.
And Niko.
My first saw him in this mirror, he was just a monster.
Now I feel like I know why he came to be.
I just have to face him.
Believe that I have the final key.
Believe.
Trust in myself.
Who's the partner?
Uh, we're gonna choose the girl!
Cause uh, Moe, Moe, Moe!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I grab them, shake their shoulder and yell.
Get it together!
There's nowhere to hide!
We have to go!
Come with me!
Hanna Hiko.
Uh, because Hanna Hiko hates adults.
Moe, Moe, Q?
Moe makes a big sound.
That's good enough.
We're going to release him from his curse!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Listen here, kid.
Okay, listen here, you- oh, okay.
Hanna Hiko is staring at Moe.
Hey, they aren't a grown-up.
I knew it!
Fine, only big people die, okay?
Sound like slithering vines come from Hanna Hiko's direction.
That's gross.
Okay, okay.
So, okay.
Review, review our notes, Senpai, before we continue.
Review our notes.
We have the weed, the plant destroyer,
and then we have the thing with the- that can stop thorns.
We're good.
That's salt water.
We got the thorn thingy that will protect us,
and we got the red stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, the umbrella.
We got them.
We got it.
The next thing I know, a sharp- small sharp object raises my face.
Missed.
You won't be so lucky next time.
I get the feeling Hanna Hiko's planning to attack me from a distance.
I need to do something to reach him from this far away.
Facing a spirit.
To defeat a spirit, you must use the item right to item at the right time.
Okay, we got- we got this.
Both you and your partner can use one item each.
Choose according to the situation.
Okay, let's use the umbrella to protect us first.
Item usage limit.
Some items are limited use, so please take care.
Check the number to the right.
Also, some items cannot be used when facing a spirit.
By the way, when did you last say uh at the mansion?
Combo actions.
When facing a spirit, two items can be used together.
This is a combo action.
It is executed if you and your partner use the right items.
Did I use- do I- okay, we have the umbrella, right?
So do we need to use the tarp and the umbrella at the same time,
or do we already have that kind of made?
I can't remember.
I can't remember if I did that or not.
I think we've already made it, right?
But someone has to hold it.
I'll figure it out.
It works as a combo?
You think it works as a combo?
Okay, we'll probably have to use the combo then.
Strategy hint.
You can read the spirit file or item descriptions at any time.
Open your bag using Y.
Okay, well.
You use- okay, oh yeah, it has to be used as together.
Wire umbrella.
Uh, a six sheet.
Yes, yes, yes.
The umbrella and then the plastic sheet.
Yes.
I put the plastic sheet over the wire umbrella.
I ready to cobble together an umbrella.
This should be able to block the thorns.
What the heck is that?
That umbrella, he's in my way.
His cold voice rings out,
sounding slightly angry.
Kind of he goes shoots a red- a rose thorn.
Thorn fires as fast as bullets,
but only bounces off the bloodstained sheet.
Yes, yes, yes, we got this.
Their blood- their blood denies him,
so that's what it meant.
The impact of the thorn causes the sheet to start to fall off the umbrella.
We don't put it back on.
We won't be able to protect ourselves.
Okay, we're close, we're close, we're close.
Kind of he goes sways closer,
as if the umbrella is irritating him.
Um, do I do it again?
Ten pies, do you think I do it again?
How close does he- does Hanahiko need to be,
so I can be like,
Behold!
Salt water!
Why do I just do salt water now?
He might be able to do something if he comes a little closer.
Okay, he has to come a little closer.
How to weaken spirits.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, one more time.
To defeat a spirit,
you must use a specific item to weaken them.
It can't be used until the spirit is as close as possible.
Okay, we have to protect again,
and then yes, yes,
we'll have to protect again,
and then we'll use the salt water,
I think,
and yeah.
And then the red thing, right?
Give me the red thing,
so the red thing I think is the lipstick.
When that happens,
the green- the screen outline will glow red,
and deer the spirits attack until they are in range.
Okay, it's not red yet,
so um, classic cheat.
Wire umbrella.
It's not red yet, is it?
Yeah.
It's still green.
Put the wire umbrella over the plastic sheet,
and he goes to choose a red thorn.
Okay, okay, is this- is this red?
Is this red?
Ten pies, is this red?
Not yet.
Do we do it again, then?
One more time.
Put the wire umbrella over the plastic sheet.
And he goes to choose a red thorn.
Is it close now?
Is it red now?
Yes, this is red!
And he goes- comes up close.
Countless vines wriggle in his oddly shaped head.
They're like poisonous snakes about to strike their prey.
At this distance, the umbrella is pretty useless.
It's obvious I'll be killed instantly if I don't do anything.
This close distance is my only chance.
Should I use an attack against spirit,
or an attack against plants?
Is there a way I can fight back?
Yeah, let's use-
The salt water,
and Moe,
the lipstick, right?
Right, right, ten pies?
We use the red- the red.
Yes, use the red!
Right?
Right, right, right!
Red!
Salt water!
Darling throws the salt water at Hanahiko!
Vines hit the salt water, quickly stops moving.
In the hazy darkness, I can see Hanahiko's face
twisting in pain.
Oh, mean.
Are you going to tease me now too, mister?
He starts sniffling as if he's about to cry.
It looks weakened.
Hanah defeats spirits!
A- defeat a weakened spirit by using specific items.
Choose an item based on the info you gathered.
You only have one chance, then carefully.
It's the red lipstick!
I got the lipstick.
Put the lipstick on Hanahiko's lips.
What did you do?
Hanahiko is weakened.
Lipstick again?
Do we use the lipstick again?
What do we do?
Ten pies!
Mirror, mirror, and then lipstick!
Lipstick!
Yeah!
Show, use lipstick!
Be gone!
Smear the lipstick on him and try to place the mirror in front.
Put the lipstick on Hanahiko and place the mirror in front of him.
He stares at his reflection.
This is red stuff.
I've been looking for this for so long.
The keepsake from my mom.
Are these memories from when he was alone?
I don't know.
Memories from when he was alive?
He smiles with his red lips.
Am I pretty?
We did it.
The spirit mounts into the darkness with a smile on his face.
I don't sense Hanahiko anymore.
Did we win?
Seriously?
Yeah.
Kind of hard to believe, but looks like we did.
Mister!
My mark disappeared!
Well, I cheers as she studies her leg.
Her mark has been burned into a right thigh.
Oh, what about yours?
Oh yeah, my right hand.
It's still there.
My mark looks exactly the same as before.
Why?
Why isn't it going away?
Sorry, mister.
It's almost gone.
Am I going to die?
So this is where you've been.
My head suddenly stopped feeling fuzzy.
Then my mark was gone.
Looks like you did it.
Yeah.
But he still has his mark.
Let's head back.
Maybe Mary knows something.
Yeah, you're right.
Come on, mister.
Let's go.
Oh, it leads the way.
Huh?
Oh, he's digging around her bag.
Oh no, my wallet's missing.
I dropped it earlier.
Her glance back at the school is confused.
But you're definitely more important right now.
We've got to hurry and get back.
Go on.
Huh?
Let's make sure you're back in five minutes.
Go get moving.
Great, great, thanks!
The boy rushes back into the school.
You're pretty calm considering.
The boy shrinks in the distance until they disappear inside the building.
The bitingly cold wind just whips past me.
It's coming from the school.
That's not normal, especially for the start of summer.
Wind dies down and out of nowhere I get a really bad feeling.
Wait, no!
I have like Moeco back inside.
Five minutes pass.
Wait, did I fuck up?
Moe isn't back yet.
Idiot, this is no time to doaddle.
Better check.
I step inside and go down the right hall.
Make it all the way to the front room where we fought Hanahiko, but...
I don't see Moe anywhere.
Strange, this should be the place.
It missed her?
Scared the crap out of me.
Fucking hell bitch, what the fuck, that was five minutes longer!
What are you doing here?
You're late so I came looking for you.
She's alive!
We saved our... our... our Kohai?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
It's dark so it took longer.
I should have borrowed the flashlight.
She bows in apology.
I'm so relieved a huge weight lifts off my shoulders when I see she's okay.
Hey, let's get a move on already.
Kohai saved a Kohai, yeah!
We all climb into the car and head straight to Kujo Mansion.
I almost thought I fucked up somehow.
I'll come back.
My mark's gone, so that must mean we beat Hanahiko, right?
This Moe seems to be okay too.
I'm pretty amazing.
Huh?
What's wrong?
You're not smiling.
Well, his mark hasn't disappeared.
What?
Why not?
Hey, darling?
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
I'll fill the pip squeak in.
You go hear what Mary has to say.
Welcome back, Lord Darling.
It appears you overcame your fear and cleared away the grudge.
Congratulations are in order.
Your tone is the same as always, but for some reason it grates me.
What's so great about it?
Why hasn't my mark vanished?
It is likely the one who gave it was not Hanahiko.
I'm suddenly light-headed, the world fading.
I'd risked my life during that investigation, and it was completely useless to me.
I guess all that's left is waiting for Dawn and my death.
Alright, darling?
Senpai, darling, is going to be constantly rizzed up by everyone in this game.
Sure is.
At least we saved everyone.
Yeah.
I thought I had a moment where I was like,
DUNNNNNNNNNNNN!
FUCK UP, I SMEEE!
If it is alright with you, would you mind showing me your mark?
I hold my arm out towards Mary.
Her neck shifts slightly as she stares at the mark.
It is as I thought.
It is only a minuscule fraction, but the fate I sensed from this mark has been distorted.
What does that mean?
Is it because I beat Hanahiko?
The flame of your life was indeed fading at one point, but now it has become brighter.
Are you saying?
What if the mark was on the butt cheek, just though?
Then I guess you have to check out your butt cheek.
She's going to have to look at your butt cheek.
Isn't that right, Senpai?
I'm not going to die at dawn.
That is correct.
My sigh of relief is so deep, it feels like my soul is escaping my body.
If only Kohai allows it.
Well, I mean, I don't want my Senpai to die, not by my hand.
So I guess you'll have to check it for me.
But at the same time, any funny business and you will die before dawn anyways.
The mark's still burned on me, but it seems I'll be okay for now.
Life or death?
Your choice, quick time events, Senpai.
It appears the mark- wait, sorry.
It appears the mark you bear is different from the other ones I know of.
But there is no doubt that it was given to you by a spirit.
Then there are other spirits like Hanahiko that gives people marks?
Yes.
Spirit-born.
Spirit-born of grudges have an insatiable hatred for the living.
This persistent hatred is not seen by simply killing the living.
Rather, they drag their victims to the depths of despair before their death.
That is what they desire.
The mark is an effective method.
Spirits who wish to terrorize the living.
The more- the more I hear them, the less I understand.
It appears something within each city can easily create such spirits.
Though I could not say what it is.
So for me to escape my mark, I need to find the spirit that gave it to me and take care of it then?
Yes, it is logical to believe the mark would disappear, the spirit.
That is the only way to escape death and regain your memories.
Great!
It will soon be done. I'm sure that you are all tired. Please rest.
You are free to use any room.
Thank you so much! Seriously! If you hadn't been there, I probably would have been killed by Hanahiko.
But when I think about you still having your mark, it's hard to be happy.
Well, I'm going to bed. Good night!
You did great work today. You're much more competent than all other adults I know.
Though it only makes sense for adults to help children.
It will be challenging from now on. My schoolwork has suffered due to my memory loss.
I need to study hard to catch up. You do your best too.
Well then, good night.
Think of, I'm heading off myself. With that mess of trouble taken care of, I'm sure I'll crash right away.
Alright, here have this.
He pulls a small paper item from his beat-up coat and hands it to me. Looks like a newspaper article.
It's about that boy who died before he was adopted. He lived with his mom.
She understood her son, unlike his hard and adoptive father.
Father should put makeup on him in front of a mirror. Very much doted on him.
After all that hell at a young age and dying, that was probably his only good memory.
Now she does smile, sad. Well, it's up to you how you interpret it. Do whatever you want. See ya!
Alright, darling, there's something I must tell only you.
About those who lost their marks, they must leave in the morning.
Those who escaped their fate should return to their daily lives. That is the will of Lady Zaya.
So I'll be the only one left behind? I feel like a student repeating a grade.
Alright, darling, by any chance, are you uneasy about being the solo occupants in this mansion?
Uh, Senpai, what should we say?
Kind of, eh? Not at all. You're here. You're here? Okay, I'll say, well, you're here.
Riz time.
Not at all? Yeah, we're gonna Riz.
I must express my extreme gratitude that you hold me in such regard. Although the things I am capable of, they are rather limited.
Mary stairs unblinkingly in. I could just be extrapolating, but it seems like she's thinking about something.
Now then, Lord Darling, it would be for the best that you take your rest as well. Please find me when you are ready.
Farewell.
Oh, she's a doll? Yeah, she's a doll.
New info was added to the spirit file. Mashi just collection of articles, other.
Uh, I forgot how to save here. Wait, next save. Ha ha!
Yeah, let's rest.
Good night.
So we can Riz the doll and, uh, not die? It doesn't count, right?
Another night greets me. It's been three days since the investigation and not one glimmer of hope for me.
Time idles by as death draws even closer to claim me.
The mark that brings death. The only way to escape it is to defeat the spirit that gave it to me.
But I have no clue where that spirit is right now. Maybe things would be different if that specialist Sayakujo was alive.
The knock breaks my train of thought.
Oh hey! Oh hey! Look, Senpai, it's our not boyfriend!
Our not boyfriend for our very manly sa-
How long do you plan on sleeping?
You're pretty relaxed for a guy who could die soon. Can you raise him up maybe?
The ex-detective Satoru, Satoru, Satoru Mashita, the other markbearer left the mansion, but he stayed behind. Mary was the cause. I guess she asked him to help as he was leaving.
She went against Sayakujo's wishes by doing that, but it seems it was for my sake.
But I don't know about Mashita. Even if he was asked to stay, he has no reason to agree.
What's that look? Not happy I stayed behind? No! Very happy!
I'm grateful! We're going to Rizz!
We're gonna Rizz, we're gonna Rizz, okay? I'm grateful.
Cut that out, it's creepy. Damn it! Damn it!
Why am I always shot down?
We have no Rizz mercy, this is what happens. Why do we have none? We can't win the maw.
Man, I was hoping that it would be like, darling.
Flatter me all you want, but I won't forget you drove without a license.
Wait, that's what you're mad about! Also, I do have a license, Senpai.
Do you have a license, Senpai? I wouldn't shoot you down, mercy. Oh, nice.
Nice! He's over mad over that!
Of course I do, okay, okay.
The criminal debuff, we have to be a good citizen now.
He's got a bad mouth, as usual. I've got my learner's permit.
What's keeping Senpai from getting the whole license?
No, sorry, Kohai, it's okay.
Learn together.
And your driving instructor called you Vomit Girl.
I still got my license.
I still got my license, even though to this day that driving instructor probably remembers me after vomiting in the car.
His true intention aside, I have to say I'm honestly grateful for his help.
Now the question is, do you have a car to use said license? Yeah.
Well, it's the family car, but I have a car.
My car is...
is a Toyota.
It's a RAV4.
My amnesia could hit without warning, so I can't go wherever I want.
A car is a car. A car is a car.
How many bad Senpais have you ran over with it?
I prefer to just chase all my own.
And how many crashes have you had?
Two. Not at fault, though.
Not at fault accidents. Both of them.
Yeah, doing it with the car isn't as intimate. You're right.
Both times was not at fault.
Is your insurance up to date? Oh, Kohai, yeah!
Were they bad crashes?
One of them was, and the other one...
My car was written off, the first car was written off,
but it was not my fault. I was parked,
I was stopped at a pedestrian crossing with pedestrians crossing,
and a car ran into my butt, the car butt,
and then I got like a concussion and stuff,
but it's not bad. I'm still here.
Were they texting and driving? I don't fucking know.
And the other one was like, just like a tiny, tiny thing.
So yeah, I was like, what the heck?
What the heck?
So yeah, it was just a long process, and I'm okay.
And I've also updated my insurance recently.
Right before, right before I joined VLR,
I updated my insurance and I was super stressed about it.
Because like, the cost of insurance went up, and I cried.
I cried a little.
Not because like, it was a while ago,
so it's not because of an accident or anything,
and my premiums went up, it's just all,
everything went up in price.
Did you remember the registration as well?
I'm registered, yeah.
I'm registered, don't worry, everything's good.
Gotta love price hikes, yeah.
Car insurance is cringe, but I have to have car insurance,
otherwise it's, otherwise it's not great.
Call hi, that doesn't sound convincing.
Well, I'm pretty sure everything's up to date, and I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure.
Mama and Papa take care of the license plates registration,
and then I just have to take care of my drivers,
my driver stuff, yeah.
Anyways, this economy sucks.
Insurance is expensive.
How often do you drive?
Oh, like almost every day, depending.
Maybe more like every other day.
More like every other day because, you know,
sometimes I want to go out with my friends, right?
Don't forget the tire change for summer and the auto change.
Surprise, shut up!
Are you a good driver?
I would say I'm a good driver.
At least a defensive driver.
Anyways, surprise, shut up!
I think everything's, I know, I know, I know.
Everything, everything, everything is fine, I think.
I think everything's fine.
Is your state inspection up to date?
I'm sure everything's fine.
What about break, shut, shut up!
Listen, as your senpais, we worry about our coil.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The jacks in the car, the spare tire is still there.
What about your air filter?
Stop!
Everything's up to date!
Everyone, yes!
The lights are fine!
I checked them!
I checked the batteries!
The oil is fine!
Gas is fine!
Brake pads are fine!
I feel like, I feel like...
I feel like, you know...
I feel like...
Senpais are like...
are like my parents now.
Did you lock it?
It's in the garage!
Did you lock your garage?
Did they lock?
It's done!
We're playing the game, Senpais!
Stop, stop, stop!
Wait, are you playing to escape using my car?
I don't know...
Senpai...
We're gonna have to teach you another lesson again!
If you really love the Senpais, you give us the key!
Yeah, I'll give you a key!
I gave you the key to my heart,
and now you're gonna betray me, you bastards!
It's time!
It's time you learn another lesson, okay?
We're gonna do...
some broken legs!
...
WAAAH!!!
I saw some people from the force!
...
still no ruckus over H Elementary.
Ugh!
that guard went missing his company should be notified that company is
exactly the issue it's run by yakuza thugs who have their eyes on the labor
department I know what the place involved plus in a shitty company like
that people up and walk out all the time yeah machita that was his name
everyone thinks he up and split here that's why they're having a hard time
finding replacement if you didn't know the school was haunted it would just be
another abandoned building the government wouldn't need to rush to find a
new guard the man lived alone so I'm missing person report won't be filed
soon the school most likely won't come under suspicion until then that's it for
my report he covered a lot of ground in a short time ex-detectives sure are
handy did you bring up the markers periods or when you were asking around do
you think I'm an idiot I'd be calling the looney bin even if the kids or I
bring them up who'd honestly believe us why waste my breath
exasperated he shrugs searching the mansion searching the mansion was on
was on you so did you find anything I came up blank as well though I only
gone through half so far and some of the rooms were lost stuck without a warrant
like you'd wait for something like that I swallowed the words before they came
out oh yeah Mary's asking for you you should get going to be fair nine out of
ten abandoned buildings are haunted are they I've been waiting for you Mary is
sitting primly on the couch the same as always
source yes have that has some pies have you seen a ghost
it appears you're having a difficult time with your investigation I do wish I
be of more use to you I know you can sense mark bearers can you send spirits
to if they were to come onto the grounds I believe I could yes ghost don't pay rent
or taxes I feel like if you ever move into into the into like a place that's
haunted I feel like I would demand the ghost to pay rent I think I would demand
the ghost to pay rent why did you bring up another I think I would force it to
pay rent probably it's only fair I think I'd like to be roommates with a ghost I
don't know they seem invasive you know invasive like you never really have true
privacy with a ghost around do ghosts have money I'm sure there's way for them
to make money that doesn't sound particularly useful do you have any
other abilities or powers like for example you know maybe they can be like a
detective like a detective and then though they can go into houses and figure
out if people are having affairs or they can you do guard stuff right maybe
they can get money they can watch people at your passwords or pins you have any
cage ghost cage for the senpais who die the senpais who die won't even have
spirits
why do you have spirits
why not they'll probably be exercised by by mama mama mercy
indeed I can view the big shape of the car course of a person's life predicting the future
a lot of me and mama mercy are cool like that
um
no no I don't think she would like it either so should probably exercise you anyways
oh no nothing quite so extreme it is more akin to fortune telling it may or may not come to pass
I get it that's why what you predicted earlier didn't actually happen
did Mary tell you something
can we just stay in the cage regardless you can stay in the cage of course
well that's your home senpai
the truth you're seeking can be found here or something such like a fool I felt
so convinced such an idiot
new characters
hey this place cool Joe mansion
I got business with some side chick
no way you huh
you
she's out I'm Sia turn to mashita she's out what do I do what I do
senpai
it's me I'm Sia
I'm Sia couldn't you tell I could always be your Sia I could be your Sia to your
I'm Sia huh you think you're a funny lion wait hold on how you think you're funny lion
anyway you guys knows her yeah would you hear me out
introductions are quickly done his name is soul Nagashima as we guess he's got a mark
he rolls up his right sleeve to show us and yep the red mark is burned in
and a cult freak friend says some
like it gives you a knee job for real
yeah that's true I can't even remember my real name you're kind of too calm for
all that
but you're pulling a fast one on me
what am I doing
that greats but the reaction is normal
but if he's not gonna believe the rumors then he's got no he has no reason to come
why is he here then
how rumors of just that I need you're on dying cuz of some mock that's comic book
craziness craziness
every word of it is true every word of it is true well what's that a ghost voice
there's a saying the truth is stranger than fiction
there are two sides of the same calling Mary begins explaining I'm sure she
figured out it would be fastest way to convince him
you got some damn speaker set up somewhere don't you don't you know I don't
take kind of wait wait I don't take kindly the threats I don't take kindly the
threats he peers closely at Mary that's a mechanism does not exist large
no way no way
he yells pathetically his eyes wide and suddenly falls flat on his ass
you seem to that despite appearances this punk is terrified of ghosts and
monsters he is tough act is likely a cover after that he meekly pays full
attention to Mary as she speaks he listens quietly his face pale as she
tells him about the mark and spirits by the time she finishes explaining his
face is devoid of color now large show have you not already experienced the
beginning of memory loss yeah I don't think he's used to marry it his face is
rather stiff my memory has always been crap so I thought I was imagining
things but now it's started so bad it was just ridiculous I got this occult
friend yeah told him about my scar the mock and he scared the shit out of me
showed me an article that said it was all the scars things fall
so now I'm here
Molly mentioned seeing an article by Sayaku Joe in a magazine to it's all
because of some monster the hell this is crazy why this has to happen to me
not believing is normal if you don't you die if you don't want to kick the bucket
figure out how you got the mark even if your memory's gone bad you should at least
remember that I'm not that far gone thanks
I think I think I definitely I'm going a little bit too silly hey I'm positive I
got in the fullest but each cast so I know I did I mean it does have a womb
about it the place being cursed so we should probably ask him more about it
forest the huge forest west of the city wait doesn't everybody everyone know
that even kids do but I've lost my memory maybe that's why I don't know about it
places the city's garbage dump bunch of nasty rumors about it there's a legal
industry industrial waste dumping there like all the time it's not just objects
either say a black car once dumped a young woman's body there a new mother
strangled her kid there because she could take it care of it did they say it
instead of of it okay yeah there's ton more rumors like that whether or not any
of them are true I heard some of those too like the gloss kid who'd eaten by dog
and they only found his torso or that murderous hides out there and kills
anyone gets near apparently while he hates ghost he's got more than fine with this
kind of stuff I've hit up the edge of the forest a few times but never walked in
no one would have a plane
what should I ask next it's cursed
a plane sorry I said plane
Joe stiffens like a board I hate that supernatural crap
I'm starting to let go we'll talk with this
just talking about it freaks me out
what a wimp
New York
rumor exists for a reason that place is a famous suicide spot 50 people die
there a year so they say and that's just what they find once there was a mass
suicide has a fair share of grizzly history
shows eyes are wide he looks like he swallowed a bug what should I ask
next why were you there I was obviously on my bike man places totally empty at
night so it's perfect for driving around riding around free as a bird helps me
clear my mind
before you ask yes I have my license and no illegal mods
huh is that so
we don't need another person flaunting the law when it's enough
I smile Riley Riley who would have thought this kid would be on the straight and narrow
that day I was clearing my head when my bike broke down
I'm so sad
I stopped to check it out then suddenly I got the scar
I definitely get any more out of show
no info on the spirit then you haven't forgotten anything no keeping secrets now
quit strong on me hold your horses I'm thinking
he's complaining but I can see he's really coming through his memories
there was some I wasn't a ghost or nothing but I did spot some weird
over by the side of the road I saw this huge man
a giant huge
sounds like you're plugging your nose oh shut up
what is this accent anymore I don't know and I'm still gonna wing it some pie and you're gonna like it
a wound
it wasn't just some trees shadow
honestly I'm not sure the place was pretty dark and I only saw it for a second
it sounds pretty heavy
is that the is that info really reliable
may I interject in truth there are a number of supernatural rumors out there
when it happens to cooperate Lord Shell's story
the rumors if she meal
it sounds like Mary has an idea
could you tell us more about it
of course Lord darling
I just tell you the story of she meal the man of the forest
he meals
I don't like this I don't like this
hey have you heard that the one about the weird giant man
he's covered in black splotches so people call him she meal the spotted man
I don't like that
I don't like that this is giving me ninja scroll the bee guy you remember the bee guy with the high one is back
I don't like that I don't like that
I've heard he asks everyone he meets a question
do you like these
college student heard the rumor decided to go to the forces
oh no oh no
oh no it's
it's gonna be ninja scroll all over again
it's gonna be ninja scroll all over the again
I really hated that guy
my try phobia is gonna go crazy
I love bees I just I like I like holes
and a man covered in splotches really did appear
no I'm not allergic to bees but I love I love bees I just don't like holes
you know like the holes the student left you like bees
yeah sure I like him and then
let's raise something
in your body
aw man
he meal as those he meets a single question
and kills them using his drill
that might that might be none other than the figure you saw on the show
however I have no proof
there are holes
there are holes in this house
then we'll have to gather evidence
let's get ourselves to the forest
investigation requires legwork
there's no hesitation in mashita
after facing hanahiko he knows full well what spirits are capable of
is this his training and experience as a police detective
ain't now you silly yes silly yes
going there in the middle of the night you guys are totally lost
you scared
what do you say I ain't no scaredy cat
hey old man take me with you instead of him
if that huge guy really is some monster
I bound him to dust
he's easy to manipulate
you've set out on a destination
you've head to the forest by each castle
once you're ready
your first goal is to identify the spirit that bestowed the mark
best wishes for your investigation
new info was added to the spirit file
the forest and shimio
new chapter item changes
all items obtained within a chapter are removed at the end
if a character brings an item it will start the edit at the start
new chapter soul power
oh we'll return to 1000
shit okay what do we have
shimio
okay
first round by a stranger fans suicides and body dumping
and the likes are scared off their casual visitor
only the occasional test of courage brings a foolish kid inside
the paths are shaded at all hours with the trees
so it's easy to become lost amongst the rumors swirling
about this forest is one of a bizarre man
a spotted man shimio
is covered in dark splotches asks
he meets if they like bees
if they say yes he attacks while laughing maniacally
he sounds like you're standard crazy
but I guess he's the next spirit will face
at any rate we'll have to head to the forest to investigate
the forest... okay
we're good
who are we gonna take
the insulin punk or the ex detective
senpai who should we take
punk
punk 100% okay
punk leaves the way
okay I guess we'll take him
let's go
oh shit you're right I didn't save
shit why am I
dammit why
she'll throw himself into the passenger seat
and mumbles an endless
litany of complaints
I really want to tell him to shut up
but I'm pretty sure that'll only make things work
it's only natural for a guy his age
hey old man you got smokes
I blank in surprise
it's a cigarette uh
I instinctively put my hand in my pocket
but then I come to my senses
you're not old enough for that yet
shut up I'm 19 already it's fine
whoa you have your answer
19 but you're still in high school
now I've done it
I've overcome with regret the instant I say it
but I can't take it back now
well it skills me for repeating the grade
oh shit
looks like I touched a sore subject
even though it wasn't my intention
oh no
senpai how can you be so callous
how can you be so callous
senpai
the atmosphere in the car was bad enough
and now I made it worse
it's okay
it's okay to repeat grades
I need to change the subject
so are you in a club or anything
how's this on us because
this the main character is senpai darling
remember
you look pretty fit so maybe baseball
or
yeah I played
but I quit
my emergency just saved
just swarmed into dangerous territory
oops
bulk bulk
rock my knee
too many laps
coach kept saying I had bad attitudes
look that I'm funny
sorry
why you apologize
I don't care about that shit
I couldn't really get into
it under that shitty coach anyway
I think I know now why he rides
his motorcycle alone in the mountains
but if he came to Kujo mansion after
I set back like that
ah fuck
it's seriously frustrating
keeps a string of swearing for a while
anyone would act the same
anyone would swear up a storm
but keep going down the same path anyway
down this dark uncertain road
that only leads to death
we arrive at the forest by H castle
I stopped the car near where Shou said
he saw the man and we entered the forest
all the guideposts on the path surfaded
their paints peeling off
it looks hardly travest
just as Shou and Mashita said
call
roll
sue
is that call
did I read it right?
I can't remember anymore
why don't we walk
a while
we come by a large arc marking the start of hiking trail
it's rested over and with the paint
peeling it doesn't seem to have been
it doesn't seem to have been touched up
the letters have faded
nor mostly
illegible
carefully reading it it says
welcome to the M
blush and romantic you are
wood timberland murder
murder
murder huh
coincidence that's all
it's just because it's way
old and faded
come on old man let's go already
we pass through the arc
and enter the forest
well let's look around first
I don't think I've been
it's been used in a long time there's no garbage littered
either
I feel around inside the container
but nothing's inside
dang it
the weather beaten
table and benches are clearly damaged
and rotting in places
feel I peek underneath the table
and find something stuck there
I found a worn out talisman
when I pick up the worn out talisman
I feel warm throw
me yes
I got soul power
the sworn out talisman crumbles silently
in my hand
I feel like I should go back
and like save
I'm gonna go back and save
yeah
let's save first
actually let's do
no yes no yes
let's save here it's a new chapter
ouch
get myself
this game has time limits
or no
no
well they have quick time events
right
okay we're back there again
it reads welcome to the lush and romantic
wood timberland
let's move forward
can you down the path a short while
before we come across something unexpected
the grave marker was probably put there
to honor those who commit suicide here
might not be a bad idea to say a quick prayer
for those who ended their suffering melee
look something's written in magic marker
say the opposite of the truth
you'll be followed
so scowled to cover how his face
is definitely pale
you'll be followed the hells with that
dammit whose scribbles dumbass graffiti
um
I guess
when it says
I mean we have to lie
just off to the side
I noticed a faint trail
discovered entrance to the beast
to the beast trail
look there's a path over there too
ailment try to keep up
what the fuck did we go
you
lying officially allowed
first see who would
you say is the
the most facile
probably me
because sometimes
I don't understand a lot of innuendos
between azura and mercy
I think
it's probably still me
it's because
it's probably still me because I don't get
a lot of innuendos
I don't know shibby's been saying you have a lot of hidden powers
what the heck has shibby been saying to you
I mean I guess
I guess
in a way
I have potential
better yet
is that a better way to say it
I
probably and second most second most unhinged or like most most not say so
would be it's a toss-up between I see and she be
like I remember you saying what's a countdown do I say the number it's kind
of embarrassing sometimes I'm like I don't know what this means and then I go
someone and they like I can feel the literal the literal like face palm as
they're typing to me you know and then I go okay yeah it's some okay okay I okay
it's something like that then it's something like that then
it's okay it's okay I'll learn
it's Johnny literally said she's the most say so I don't think Johnny is the
most say so I don't think strong is the most say so let's just say that I don't
think strong is the most say so because sometimes while we're together she says
the most unhinged just things and I just go
she just says things and I go okay the moonlight doesn't reach the beast trail
the branches off the hiking trail so we're in gloom gloom the trees are thick
on both sides and I think her favorite thing she likes to tell me is like I'm
so glad we don't have an HR just department the trees are thick on
both sides we'd get lost if I didn't have a flashlight just then fuck off
there are footsteps close by from the bushes hold on did you hear footsteps
too I think strongy is like from like most say so to like I'm say so to these
say so strongy is above me because sometimes she can be pretty innocent
too I hear footsteps again it better be a fucking dear it better be a motherfucking
dear it seems to be getting closer then what okay it's a person
corporate slaves spotted salary man spotted a man appears from the bushes he
looks horribly exhausted don't start on me like that you should stand around in
the dark what are you doing here what are you doing man fall silent I think he
realized he already knows the answer we can talk about this we can talk about
this nothing scarier than the nine to five I know we can talk about this sir
Meshita did say this place is a famous spot for suicide no no no no no wait no
no no no no it will get better I just can't do it anymore work myself to the
bone at a job I don't even want okay fair fair but and you just bring another
man home how dare you the nerve he holds his head in his hands he suddenly
starts kicking a tree and yelling okay understandable understandable um listen
she's not worth it she's not worth it man she's not worth it you know there's
tons of fish in the sea heck you can even be another oji-san
fuck fuck a rapid stream of swear words flow out of his mouth
you seems to be the type that goes crazy when he's upset
hey could you tell me how much nerve do you have to do that huh
listen I know I know you're going through a hard time I know you're going
through a hard time man but like you know this isn't the answer this is in the
answer
stop him death and vice-death
how do we how do we calm down
Sampai's I've been in therapy! Sampai! Sampai we have to how how do we calm this man down
wait do I have to tell him the opposite of the truth
wait
is he just a dog
opposite of the truth is this the hint is this the truth
Emmy NO!
I heard that voice again
thank you for the super chat for two shut the fuck up hear that voice again I
think that would just make him more angry
stop it does that mean I should dissuade him
if you got some if you got something say just spit it out you bastard
I'm bad I'm bad I'm bad at this I'm bad at this okay I can't come for for shit
I'm sorry I have the tism
ah live or die shit
sympathize sympathize I think sympathize with him right
it'd be bad if we went berserk here I try to act like I sympathize but no no no
you say you understand okay maybe I've calmed him down
what budget are you trying to pull huh
they only mean it worse
I think so power lost wrong
what did you think I was doing
I lost quite a bit worth myself sick but stuck with it anyway for who's sake I'm
not good at this the tism the tism
I even bought her a person or anniversary last year
yeah man yeah fuck
damn it damn it then she goes and sees another man man curse the darkness he's
completely lost it I should probably avoid any tackless interaction our
flattery
what does this mean don't be a bitch
and you there wasn't me
this is hard I can't understand people
it was her it was her but yeah it was her what do you think clear this up for me
did I do something wrong
ah
it was her it was definitely her
someone's here no
yeah that's right I just did my best I can hear the English in his voice as he
yells I'm gonna fucking die I'm sure she just laughed if she heard I was dead
hang off her asshole lover but when I think about it you know it's strange I
don't have to make her happy when it caused me so much pain I'm gonna I'm
gonna fucking I'm gonna fucking die ridiculous I'm done with it no way I'm
gonna die for an idiot like that that's right I'm sure I can still man looks
down on his feet thing glasses up at me start over fresh right
uh
keeping quiet huh everyone's always looking down on me I'm not gonna do what
you want man runs off into the darkness laughing I'm so fucked he's gone
we might have to start over Senpai we might have to start over Senpai
well what a what a pain in the ass
huh someone else
before I realized it a huge figure looms up behind me
we lost you know what we lost because of social interaction I can't understand
people let's do it from the last save I can't believe we lost because I am too
to Tism I am too too too not not good at social interaction
oh I can't believe we lost because of that social skills made us lose
ah man I can't I can't man
social skills dying to be anti-social I think I'm pretty social but I'm not a
good I'm not a good person to like de-escalate things that's my social
awareness I'd like de-escalating I that's not me I don't know how to de-escalate
things are read people well I'm I don't know anyways I want to go take an idol
meeting okay clearly we're not that good either I don't know I don't know how to
I need to think like do we listen to him or do we be like yeah it's it's it's
terrible I feel like I don't know I feel like comforting people is like so
difficult game said not to be tackless and people said to do no um
it's hard I don't know I don't know there's a one person where it's like oh
shit there's something there maybe that was the right answer for one of them but
I don't know the rest I don't know the rest man he doesn't want flattery so do we
just be like stop being a hole okay so you got the first part okay it's the
first part we like just listen to him like rant I guess the one where it says
hey there's a person here we should have that's probably the one what's the
second one
like oh anyways I need to be there I mean I need a golden I don't mean
be happy
what are you doing what are you bartering some pie what are you bartering
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
hey mercy how's the pet it was a night I'll meeting
it was a night I'll meeting what are you talking about
I heard something go hi that's something between you and I some pie
that's the meeting about all you know things and stuff
as the idle meeting productive
they say we're ready oh yeah shut the fuck up Senpai
yeah okay okay oh we'll go through this again
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah grab this look
nothing there I think there was something was there something on the table no oh
did we collect that already yeah wait we probably did collect that already never
mine wash your hands check I did okay let's go forward again you continue down
the path blah-blah-blah grade marker we say our prayers look it's written on
magic marker baby opposite of the truth you will be followed yep yep
a fake trail okay now we're back to this guy proof proof that I wash my hand
what do you want you want to touch my hands and be like yeah it smells like
lemon soap okay okay okay we're ready this time right we're ready this time
right Senpai okay sniff go on Senpai sniff okay first one we listen to him
right I was gonna go impossible I think that would be the right answer because
it's like no bullshit right okay okay okay we got the Senpai
we failed last time because I am socially inept but we got this this time
thanks to Senpai's I know how to talk to a person now okay you can't do it
anymore try to use this lemon soap oh my gosh twinsies yeah the nerve the nerve
of that a harlot yeah starts kicking a tree
swear yeah yeah yeah yeah mm-hmm
okay oh yeah we got to save him hey man he's the vent right I trust you Senpai I
trust you Senpai you said to listen and now I will listen live or die
finally listen it would be bad if he went berserk here I'll just have to hear
him out okay okay okay but it seems the man misinterpreted my silence oh do
you feel the same way wait wait it worked okay yay of course you do you're
in this forest after all yeah you're so smart what did you think I was doing
worked myself sick but stuck with it anyways for who's sake oh I even brought
her a person our anniversary last year oh you're right this one I don't know
completely lost it I should probably avoid any tackless injection or flattery
hey you wasn't me do you think clear this up for me did I do something wrong oh
shit wait oh someone's here yeah that's the one right what the man's gaze starts
around nervously and he mutters quietly could it be that creepy guy he checks
around on full alert satisfied that no one's there he resumes speaking okay
I'm sure he should just laugh if she heard I was dead being off her asshole
lover but when I think about it you know it's strange okay we give him tough love
okay we give him tough love
why do I have to make her happy when it caused me such pain ridiculous done with
it no way am I gonna die for an idiot like that that's right I'm sure I can
still man looks down at his feet thing laces up at me still start over fresh
right now man okay okay it's impossible that's the tough love right
Senpai yeah I agree yeah Senpai this is good this is good sometimes they're
teaching me how to have a talk to a person I live this long it's too late
for me
Senpai's did it Senpai's did therapy I'll die sometime soon even if it's not
tonight I'll endure it until then
whoa we did it Senpai I don't know what you've been through but you should
rethink it honestly though you look like you'll be fine the expression changes
as he remembers something it's all strange man where I was wandering around
out here this body was covered of black splotches thank you sick kept staring at
me was creepy I think I think we did it yeah we did it we saved him if you're
heading back be careful man covered in splotches Mary brought up some rumors
about man like that oh yeah I forgot to mention his name is the names Massile
Kimura if we ever meet again man snap scratches his head and smiles a bit let
me buy you a drink or something well see you you didn't call high you're
officially a therapist doctor I'm now official I need to go back and save
again I can't do this I'm not gonna do this again he don't talk long with
Massile Kimura before he leaves new info was added to spirit file man at the
brink of suicide damn what a pain in the ass
guys like that should hurry up and die shut the fuck up so shut the fuck I say
that again punk and you're gonna meet some scissors wall there the beast trail
continues onward let's return to our investigation yeah by return to my
investigation I mean we're going back and we're gonna go save again I'm safe
scumming I'm safe scumming absolutely no fucking chill right
ah
that's so mean what the hell's wrong with you kid
like at first I was I I like sympathize that you like did another grade but now
you're like a bit of an asshole like a little bit a lot of an asshole I didn't
feel this did I feel it there's the gray marker but nothing's unusual about it
other than the graffiti anything else around here
okay Jesus Jesus
there was a light there wasn't there I go to open the door and my hands get
coated with a sticky liquid
I smell sweet is it honey
Why would there be honey on a doorknob?
Mystified, I step inside the cottage.
I sure hope as fuck there's nothing here.
How about that, it's clean.
It's been a night here, easy.
I don't like the look of that, that, that bag.
Ignore shows rambling and take a good look around the cottage.
Not sure why, but something feels off.
It takes me two seconds to figure it out.
It's too clean.
Huh, show looks at me startled.
Don't you think it's strange?
Why would a building that's been abandoned for so long get this clean inside?
Oh.
I don't even have to look to know his face just turned three shades whiter.
Saying someone lives here?
I don't know for sure, but it's possible someone comes here occasionally.
That or I immediately start shining my flashlight on places of interest.
Maybe I should have brought the cough instead.
What do you think's in this bag?
Pretty big.
How should I know?
If you're so interested in it, why don't you open it already?
She'll give me the go-ahead, so I open the burlap sack.
Before I can stop it, it loses its balance and topples it to the floor.
She'll's eyes open wide again.
Just a gasp.
Ugh.
Senpai!
Not again!
Senpai not done!
Hold on.
Senpai, don't look.
Don't look.
Don't look, Senpai.
Senpai, don't look.
I don't even know where to cover first.
There, there.
YouTube, YouTube, this is fine.
While it rolls onto the floor, it's a corpse.
A woman.
What's with that body?
The body is drilled with countless holes.
A sharp cylindrical tool must have gouged them.
Please, please, please don't tell on me, Senpai.
Even otter, her whole body appears to be covered in liquid.
Why did, why did you have to say it like that?
A thick sweet scent fills the air, strong enough to make you want to cough.
Is this honey?
Honey?
Stop looking, Senpai!
On a corpse?
Why?
He's not really asking me, obviously.
There's no way I'd know.
Should I've gotten a cough instead?
He would handle this much better than a teenager,
more technically still in his teens.
One more year.
I don't like holes either, so.
Cool.
All I do know is we need to get out of here.
As soon as possible.
Let's hurry and search the rest of the cottage.
What?
You're gonna look around?
What, what are we gonna do about this?
He's not expecting us to take it, is he?
Close the bag, put it back.
That's all we can do.
Come on, help me out.
Hey, this isn't the time to be freaking out.
Actually, yes it is.
Cool, it's freaked out.
Sweating profusely, we managed to get the job done.
Okay, that was, that was pretty disturbing.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah, actually, that was pretty, you know.
That was...
Holes are rough?
I told you, Senpai, I hate holes!
I still need to search the rest of the cottage.
New info was added in the spirit file.
Carps in the cottage.
What, what was it, trypophobia or something?
Yeah, I have trypophobia.
I hate it.
I hate it so much.
Okay, what are these books?
Look.
Honeybees are our friends.
Make them ammoable with medicine from the sprayer.
They get mad.
Pay attention to the direction the hive is facing.
Awaken to honeybees.
Leave the hive in the direction of the sun.
Go.
Honeybees are our friends.
No.
It looks like something useful.
Information.
Should I rip it out and take it with me?
Burrow the page.
Make hive, new body, smear honey all over.
Ferment, honey gets stinky, stinky liquid!
Thank you for the tip and on.
Thank you, Mercy.
Oh, and sorry, I missed the super chat.
Thank you for the $2 super chat, boy.
And welcome to being in my merryuki.
Stinky, huh?
Gone by smell, honey bee enter hive.
Looks like some useful information.
Should I rip it out and take it with me?
Yeah.
I'm going to need to remember that.
A bottle of drugs is all in line.
Look, the labels say night night.
Also, the bottles are empty.
I shake each one and luckily find one that still has some left inside.
But night night.
I remove the lid and look inside, but all I find is dust.
Okay, useless.
Meadow to a box.
Locked.
There's no way to open it.
Can I feel it?
There's thin layer of dust built on the outside.
No one has touched it for a long time.
I love this one.
Peek through the cracks to see if anything's inside, but seems to be empty.
Anything else?
I flip the switch at the base of the light bulb, but it doesn't turn on.
Maybe it's broken.
Can we get this later, Senpai?
Do you think we're done, Senpai?
Save just in case?
I don't think I can save here.
Boxes in the corner of this one?
Oh, they said there was nothing but dust inside.
Open the door and let the cabin.
Okay.
We're going to save scum again.
We're going to save scum again because I think we can only save at Kujo Mansion?
I don't actually remember.
Okay, well, we haven't taken this trail yet.
Shut the fuck up!
Sorry.
As we continue through the dense forest, the pain cries suddenly echoes amongst the trees.
Do I have to?
Nice hand.
There's a pattern on the tree trunk.
It's an arm-like pattern on the bark.
Is this even a natural occurrence?
Look around the tree and find a talisman on the exact opposite side of the tree from the pattern.
Yes! A worn-out talisman!
We did it!
When I pick up the worn-out talisman, I feel warmth flow through me.
Give me back my stuff!
Thank you!
Got soul power.
Or now a talisman crumbles silently in my hand.
Anything else?
Move forward.
I don't see anything.
Keep moving forward.
Wait, is this another one?
Look, something's written in Sanskrit.
But the letters are blurry.
It just looks like a stain.
Off to the side, I notice a thin trail.
Down the beast trail.
Thought so.
There's one here too.
Come on, let's go.
Follow Sho into the bushes.
Ugh!
Not you again!
Sho spots something.
Something instumbles, calling backwards onto me.
At the same time, every single hair on my body stands on end.
Hi!
I quickly look down and find a guy!
Something is clinging onto my ankle.
It's expression anguished.
Is this where we tell the opposite?
Is this where we lie?
It seems eager to speak for me,
but his voice is incredibly hard to decipher.
This place pitch black.
Something can't see anything.
I can't see what he is.
I don't know what the last one is.
What do you think?
What do you think that the third word is?
The third thingy?
What's it saying?
Goon?
Goon, goon.
Okay, okay.
Goon.
Wait, that grade marker said,
say the opposite of the truth.
Okay, okay, okay, we're good.
But what's the opposite of the truth?
Does that mean I'm supposed to lie?
Yeah.
Live or die.
Again, okay.
Hey, wait.
Are you?
Lifeless too?
What does that mean?
No, no, no, I'm not, right?
Oh, wait, yes, we are li-
Yes, we are lifeless.
Yes, we lie.
Yes.
I am.
It looks sad and lonely.
I-
Right.
Okay, right?
Only the dead are here.
Safe.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Quick.
I hear another voice at my feet.
M-
M-M-M-I, dead.
No, no, you're not dead.
Right?
No, no, no, no, no, no, you're not.
No, no.
Oh.
Don't-
I don't believe it.
I don't understand.
Am I?
Okay, am I?
What?
You dead?
No, no.
Tell me.
Are you dead?
Am I dead?
No.
No, no.
Deny it.
Yeah.
No, no, you?
No.
Look at you.
Look at your pink skin and the soft-
soft flushes of your-
your- your cheeks.
Yeah.
Look at you.
So much life in your eyes.
No, wait.
I still have to suffer- suffer.
Along with your complexion.
It looks sad and lonely.
Okay, okay.
Another lie.
I hear yet another voice at my feet.
Someone, please listen.
I want to live.
Okay.
Or is it I want to love?
Like, 75s love me, right?
I- I'm-
I'm alive.
Wait.
Senpai's help.
Do I say, yep, you are alive.
Yep, you are.
Do I say that?
Or do I say the opposite of what they're saying?
No, wait.
I lie, right?
Yep, you sir.
You sure are.
We need to lie.
Yeah, we need to lie.
So therefore, we got to go like, oh, yeah.
Yeah, you are so alive.
Uh, step on the ghost.
Not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you're alive.
You're alive.
That's right.
I'm alive.
The voice sounds like it passes through me
and sucked into the ground.
Safe.
Woo!
The stuff ending.
Next thing I know, the shadow clutching at my ankle is gone.
Survive.
Whoa, we did it, Senpai.
Show stands there, his face deathly pale.
No way.
I saw it.
God, it was so clear.
It's OK.
It's over now.
Right.
Oh, man.
Oh, what?
You're awesome.
Are we bonding after you said that guy needed to die?
Well, he's certainly straightforward.
Sure, let's go.
Yeah.
Is there anything at the end of this footpath?
What the hell is this?
Look, carefully approach it, but I don't see any bees.
Open the box and find a metal tool inside.
Got crowbar.
Oh, what's this doing here?
Why not grab it?
I don't think there's anything else.
Guess we go through the thing.
Step into the empty clearing.
The air is filled with buzzing of bees.
There appears to be a giant beehive there.
This probably wouldn't be right to keep going without doing something about them first.
These things are dangerous.
Dangerous.
Oh, man, don't push your luck.
Don't push your luck.
You beat a hasty retreat.
Shit.
OK, so what now?
What's the bee note say again?
They said, but we need like a spray thingy.
Hold on.
Let me look at my memos.
Oh, Azura.
Welcome in Raiders.
Welcome, Azura.
Welcome to the stream.
Hello, Raiders.
How was one shot?
Did you finish?
Azura.
Azura, did you finish one shot?
Welcome, Raiders.
Welcome to the stream.
You already know me.
I'm Mercy Modiste.
I've arrived and no, it was much longer than I thought.
Oh, OK.
Well, you have another stream.
Don't worry.
Welcome, everyone.
Today we are playing a game called Deathmark.
It's like a visual novel with some quick time events.
Yeah.
So yeah, it's a visual novel, horror visual novel.
What's in my bag?
Hold on.
OK, honey bees are friends.
Make them friendly with medicine from the sprayer.
If they get mad, pay attention to the direction the hive is facing.
Awaken honey bees.
Leave the hive in the direction of the sun.
Make hive new body smear.
Honey all over her.
My honey gets stinky like we draw my smile.
Honey, enter hive.
OK.
Can be used with a sprayer.
I don't have a sprayer.
The goat is going to head to bed.
I leave the bleeding hearts in your care.
Behave, everyone.
OK, thank you, Azura.
And if anyone else is tired, yeah.
Yeah, feel free to go to bed and just rest up.
Thank you.
Thank you, Azura, for bringing everyone in.
Yeah, behave.
Did I miss something?
Hold on.
Hold on every, every, every senpai.
We can't go to the side yet.
But I need a bee sprayer or anything.
Maybe I missed something at the cottage.
I think I missed something at the cottage senpai.
Probably.
Let's look around again.
Open the box with a crowbar.
Oh, right.
Yes, you are right.
You are right.
We can probably open it with a crowbar.
Anything else?
Let's go in.
Crowbar.
Take out the crowbar and shove it under the lid of the toolbox.
I put pressure on it.
Use it as a lever.
Throw a box prop.
It's open.
Got a sprayer.
We got it.
And I can use a variety of drugs.
Manipulators will themselves be manipulated.
What does this mean?
What's that thing?
The sun voice makes me jump but I shake it off and turns towards him.
It's a tool that sprays chemicals and pesticides.
You put the container of drugs in here and then do this.
I quickly demonstrate how it works.
Shoal scratches his head, his face, and his brow furls.
You sure know a lot, oh man.
I guess we don't manipulate a person?
No more lying, okay.
I'll let you handle it then.
Now I'm suddenly in charge of it.
Well, I want, when I want to spray a drug, I'll have to choose which drug to use.
But is this thing really that hard to figure out?
I've never seen it before either,
but I still know how to use it right away.
Uninfo was added to spirit pile.
Obtain sprayer.
Can I use, oh yeah, wait, this one has nothing in it.
Okay, yeah, yeah, Senpai smart.
Senpai smart, let's get the fuck out of there.
I don't think we're old, but I guess
according to Shoal, we're older than him, so I guess that's fine.
Okay, we're gonna,
we're gonna save scum.
Wait, am I not, wait, where am I?
Oh, okay, there we go.
I know which way I'm facing now.
Okay, so now we can use the night knight on, on the bee stuff.
Step into the empty clearing.
Okay, air is filled with the buzzing of bees.
Okay, then appears to be a giant beehive here.
Probably wouldn't be wise to keep going without doing something about it first.
Oh yeah, there's that.
Take out the sprayer and hold in one hand.
Should be able to use this to spray drugs.
Okay, bag?
Or can I just go?
Shoal, night knight?
Take out the night knight and put in the sprayer.
I take careful aim and spray the drug.
Oh, I should have been wearing,
I should have been wearing goggles for that.
The bees movements get slower.
Eventually the hive falls completely silent.
Mercy, how do you like the game so far?
It's great.
I think the only time, senpai, where I was, I like,
I rage quit like a series.
I think was index, where the one character I found out was 15 years old.
I should show, show senpai's the character, hold on.
I know this is, we're, we're taking a small intermission.
I forgot what his name is.
Senpai!
Thank you for this five dollar super chat.
I rewatched the stream.
My apologies for drunken ramblings.
We'll lock up phone next time before I get,
I guess very blessed, very unprofessional life.
That's okay.
It was funny.
Hold on.
I'm going to save this image.
Not a web.
I'm going to screenshot this.
Hold on senpai.
I got this.
I got this senpai.
Okay, okay.
And then we'll add it to, to as an image file.
Careful, don't talk to yourself.
I'll, I'll be, I'll be extra careful.
And then it should be the last one.
This character!
This freaking character!
Senpai is 15 years old!
I like rage quits so hard.
I'm like, no fucking way!
He's 15.
I was like, damn!
Are you serious?
Wiki says 14, I was even more worse!
It's worse than I thought!
It's 14!
Nevermind!
Nevermind, he's 14.
That's even worse.
I thought, I remembered it completely wrong.
No, he's 14.
That's totally wrong.
Is there some magic or some synapse?
Is there some magic or some synanigan involved?
No.
I don't think so.
This kid's fucking 14.
It has to be a mistranslation, right?
Oh, 14 now makes sense.
Come on.
Anyways, yeah, that's the character.
That's the character.
I, um, I like kind of rage quit.
I might pick it up again, but oh!
It just took me out of it.
I was like, no way.
I like, I was so into it and then that happened.
I was like.
Oh, I can't do it.
It's worse that it's not 15.
It's 14.
Oh man.
It's fine.
So fine.
But yeah, because we were talking about ages.
Doesn't the teacher look like an actual child also?
I don't remember, but I do remember just being shell shocked by,
by this kid and then just going, I can't do this man.
Okay, let's continue.
Okay.
So eventually the hive come.
Well, it's completely silent.
Used up one bottle of night night.
I've silenced every hive in this area.
Now we can pass through.
Yes.
All right.
Way to go.
Oh man.
You got this.
Anything else?
No spooks.
What the fuck was that?
Whoa.
Did you just hear some kind of animal?
I heard it and sounds familiar.
Sorry, my stomach does kind of sound like someone's stomach.
Huh?
I say you wouldn't happen to have any night night yourself.
I have a lot of chlorophyll.
Farm, chlorophyll, yeah.
Oh wait, it's probably the bunny.
Turning around.
I wonder if it's, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the bunny.
It's bunny.
Yep.
That rabbit hops in front of me.
Evo she be.
She be with her tan?
Toggle stop.
A bunny?
The rabbit's scare stares at us completely still.
It's almost like it's waiting for us to follow.
Hey, wait.
The next thing I know, I'm rushing after it.
Hey, hey, where do you think you're going?
Oh man, rabbit.
What's that H elementary?
It showed us up and guided us when we were in trouble.
Maybe the rabbit is good.
We shouldn't judge a book by its cover.
That's not some normal rabbit.
It's definitely acting with intent.
At last, the rabbit guides me too.
The fuck is this?
An old Shinto Tori gate.
It looks evil as shit, Kohai.
Well, what do you think I look like then?
Do I look evil to you, Senpai?
I'm super nice though, right?
Yeah, you look more phone friendly.
Seriously?
Of course not.
There's a heart on your face.
Broken.
Yeah, you look like a lot.
Evil but cute.
Why not the rabbit then?
Why not the rabbit?
It looks evil but cute.
What, purple and friendly isn't evil?
That's good, no?
What about a rabbit then?
A rabbit's cute, right?
There's a shrine here?
The rabbit's cute but evil.
There's a difference.
Okay, evil mercy be like I was supposed to be purple.
Purple's royalty and mercy is our queen.
Senpai.
Thank you Senpai.
I call it shadow sheebie, then we should follow it.
We should follow it.
Anything with red eyes should be instant red flag,
except for you.
I have red eyes.
Yeah, actually, yeah, I do have red eyes.
I don't know, it's kind of, yeah, it's red, right?
Purple's also the color corruption.
What?
Senpai, what are you implying?
Thank you, Nekohai, for joining.
Joining, I'm out of here.
Joining them buzz.
The rabbit looks back at me,
then soundlessly turns, it turns from the gate
and hops into a bush nearby.
Hey, old man, don't mess with me like that.
You're nuts running off like that.
The hell's with that bunny anyway?
Something's bothering me about it.
Sorry, I think that's totally a wrong voice.
I lost sight of it here, though.
Just then, from out of the darkness.
Not the bees!
Why, I order.
Torrigate kind of messed up, yeah.
Bees!
A huge swarm of bees is sending us on us.
Shit, watch out!
There are bees everywhere!
And damn, we gotta get out of here.
Sho pulls my arm and we stumble back to the earlier crossroad.
The info was added to the spirit file, mysterious shrine.
Shit.
Oh no, there's some rope there.
No!
Hey, Senpai, which way do we turn?
Left or right?
Turn around?
Right?
Okay.
The buzzing of bees killed the area.
Looks like there's another giant beehive there.
Probably wouldn't be wise to keep going without doing something about them first.
Take up the sprayer and hold it in one hand.
Be able to use spray drugs.
I don't think, Senpais, I don't have enough.
I don't, I don't think I have any more, more, more night night.
Punch the beehive, Mercy.
That sounds like a terrible idea.
Okay, what about...
Oh, okay, we come back to the Torrigate again.
Can't you maybe add in a little spray, some drugs on the bees or something?
Even the sprayer could calm them down, but...
There's a hive above the gate too.
There's no way I can spray up there.
Damn, I can't do that, huh?
But something might be at the shrine.
True enough, but that time the rabbit brought me here,
it didn't try to go inside the gate.
Maybe there's no reason to force our way in.
Yeah, okay, bye!
Okay, we're driven away.
Um, left this time?
Another one, okay, no.
I don't have enough night night.
But these aren't that violent, these ones are.
I move forward.
Where the hell am I?
When did these get here?
Look, noticeably dirty as if someone hasn't been here looking after it,
and moss is growing on its back.
Had around the Giso statue to search it.
There's a strange texture on its moss covered backs.
When I brush away the moss, I find a yellowed paper stuck to the statue.
Found a worn out talisman.
When I pick up the worn out talisman,
I feel warmth flow through me.
Got soul power.
Worn out talisman crumbles silently in my hand.
There's some sly sliding wooden doors.
Look, small crack between the doors.
I can only imagine it creates a bad draft.
Feel.
Lighting door won't open, they seem to be locked.
Can I use the crowbar on it?
I got the crowbar and jamming into the door.
Yeah, yeah, do it!
It's the fastest way.
Can't break the lock.
Or my body weight behind the crowbar two or three times then.
There's a sound of metal breaking.
What?
Crowbar snaps completely into two pieces!
Shit.
Lost crowbar and got broken crowbar.
Too much force, old man.
At least the lock up busted too.
Good.
Hurry it up and look inside.
But you're going inside with me, right?
You overdid it, man.
The door's a mess.
You made it even harder to open now.
Push the door open and step inside.
Only to run into something.
Stop, stop!
Don't come close, any closer.
If you come any closer, I'll sue.
A woman has backed up in a defensive stance.
I'm a black belt in Taekwondo.
Oh, okay, we have a normal woman.
If you try anything, Al.
Shut up, old lady!
Old?
At Chills' Roar, the woman treaks and falls silent eyes wide.
Incredibly rude, but honestly, I'm grateful.
We wait for the woman to calm down before asking what she's doing here.
Forgive me, it was all a misunderstanding on my part.
I'm Kristi Arimura, freelance news anchor.
Oh, I haven't done much recently.
Wait, I've seen you!
You're the woman that was in the news!
Wow, that's really true!
Celebrity is on a more beautiful person!
Get that out, this isn't the time for flattery.
She says that, but she doesn't sound that upset.
She seems to love being complimented.
Speaking of senpai...
Oh, where's my compliment?
Kohai's cute, yay!
Best Kohai.
Beautiful mercy, yeah.
Yeah, that's the stuff.
Thank you, thank you senpai!
Yay!
Aww, senpais!
Senpais are so nice to me.
Yay, thank you!
Um, anyway, what are you doing here?
Your expression clouds over.
Well, feel huffed at me.
You really have to ask!
You lost your tack in your old age!
Masao Kimura's face comes to mind.
That's right, this place is...
I was going to die.
Yes, I know, full well just how stupid that is.
But sometimes that's the only choice you have left.
I shouldn't have known better of such a thoughtless question past my lips.
Wow, we really have no riz.
Zero, none!
It's a woman, so you know how to de-escalate, right?
No!
We are so riz-less senpais.
How could we?
I wish I could blame the mark for this.
Oh yeah, I heard something about you fooling around with another celebrity.
Like, is call- is- is call-hi-mercy?
Riz-less?
No, we are riz-less.
Not that I care about that stuff.
That's why I came out here, so I wouldn't cause trouble for anyone.
At the very end, I thought about calling someone, but couldn't so...
I made up my mind.
But- but then in the forest...
I have a bad feeling about this.
What was... in the forest?
A huge man.
An extremely huge man.
I don't know, I'm not even sure if he was really human or not.
But I saw a figure like that.
I suddenly got scared.
I ran into this cottage.
I'm here to kill myself and I just run from danger.
I'm a riot.
What- what's wrong?
You two aren't saying anything.
That's the same as what I-
Yeah.
Christy must have seen shimmy-o.
Which means she must also.
You got in a weird scar recently.
One that stings every now and then.
I know the answer just from her reaction.
How'd you know?
I- I only just noticed it myself.
There's a strange bite mark on my palm.
This is crazy.
Someone receives the mark when they're already planning suicide.
The height of irony.
Hey old man, what are we supposed to do now?
That lady came to offer self, you know?
There any point in helping her?
Well, what if she changed her mind?
Shut up!
Help me!
I'm not going to kill myself anymore.
I swear, so please, I'm terrified of him.
Her eyes are serious.
She must mean what she says.
I only be a temporary change of heart, but...
Alright, we'll help you.
Our home base is Kujo Mansion.
You need to go.
Stop messing with the flies!
Ashlight, old man!
Sampai!
What's happening?
Sampai's...
We might be...
We're in thwobble.
I'm in danger!
Well, I won't turn on.
What's happened before about back then?
I got it to go back on right away.
Aaaaaaahhh!
But this time, it's not working.
What was that?
Aaaaaaahhh!
No, I'm from behind the cottage!
Is something there?
Shit, there's no use.
I gave up on the flashlight and stuff it in my bag.
What's the plan now?
Do we bunker down in this cottage?
We can't even lie.
We have to run out of the forest.
Are you insane?
This day here will be suicide.
This place is strangely clean.
That means someone is coming here.
I mean, she comes here?
Let's go. We walked all the way here.
We should know how to get back.
You're seriously going? Are you mad?
Sorry, but we're out of time.
Stay here if you want. I won't stop you.
Aaaaaaahhh!
Step out of pitch-clackness.
Damn it, I can hardly see.
We need to go straight.
We need to get out of here.
Step out of pitch-clackness.
Damn it, I can hardly see.
We need to go straight back
to the entrance with no detours.
I was lost on the way here, so...
I don't know.
Not as bad as you think it is.
Ah, shit.
We've got no idea where he could be waiting.
You remember the way, right, Mercy?
I got lost in the middle.
Where's Leemina Rush?
I hadn't split them out.
I would never finish.
My voice is starting to shake too much.
Maybe I should save before we're in an entire spot.
Can I save?
I'm not at the mansion!
New info was added to the spirit file.
A markbearer in a cottage.
Okay.
Back.
We're at a fork already.
Which way?
Where do we go?
I don't remember, Senpai.
Was it...
Was it forward?
Left?
I don't know if that's right.
Maybe it is left?
I think right is the tori gate.
Left was a bee path.
Would it be forward then?
Forward then?
Oh my gosh.
Can you read the map?
I think east.
We came from the east.
Never... Which way is east?
Right, okay.
Okay.
Yeah!
Don't yell, lady!
Something's coming closer.
We need to get out of here fast.
Uh...
East?
Forward.
Another fork?
Which way this time?
South. It's south!
The exit should be straight ahead from there.
Quiet.
Something's passing through the bushes right by us.
Now the game tells us that's good.
Is he following us?
Even if he was, he is.
We have to keep going.
That's no way we can just stand around anymore!
Right, let's go!
Move around.
Move forward.
Wait a second.
No, wait a second.
I see something stops.
What's wrong?
What's coming?
I'm telling you, someone's coming.
Not from the darkness jumps.
Mashita!
So this is where you were.
You're closer than I thought.
Wait, why are you here?
I had a bad feeling, so I grabbed a car and made my way here.
Looks like you're in an erupt spot.
Can you say that again?
Anyway, we're on our way back.
Good plan.
Mashita glances over at Christie.
Run! Run now!
Explain later! We gotta get out of here!
We reach the entrance safe and sound.
The creepy murderer on the Ark is such a familiar sight now.
Alright, if we made it this far, then we must be...
Yeah, it's all good now.
Christie doesn't move.
She looks worried, staring off into the forest entrance.
What's wrong?
Over there.
Doesn't it look like someone's there?
She's looking at the picnic table, hiding in the gloom next to the gate.
The gaze is drawn over as if by magnets.
What is...
No!
No, we just saved him!
Is he having a beer?
What is that?
The scene before me is strange.
No!
Wait, is he having a beer too?
Are they drinking beer together?
That's kind of nice, but also...
We just saved him!
He was gonna have a drink with us!
The huge misshapen man with beads crawling all over his face.
The eyes fixate on his mouth.
Looks like he's laughing.
My heart thunders painfully,
and I catch a glimpse of the limp figure sitting beside him.
It's him, that man.
He's going to commit suicide.
Masao Kimura, it's definitely him.
Control those that are different in exercise.
That strange voice echoes in my head again.
My vision warps.
He's dead?
Kimura's dead?
What? Why is he on that bench?
My legs give out when I finally focus enough.
I find myself kneeling on the ground.
Oh man, keep it together!
It's still okay, he hasn't seen us!
We have to escape while we can.
You see, he's completely out of it.
She won't move an inch unless someone drags her.
Let's go.
We're going to the parking lot.
You bring her.
You got it!
Come on, Mashita, let's go.
Mashita?
He's gone.
Took my eyes off him for two seconds
and he's not by the bench anymore.
The machine growls
and the undergrowth near us rustles.
Yeah, he's right there!
Run!
Mashita yells, scrambling away.
The hollow
bang rings out from behind me.
A gunshot?
Must be Mashita.
I had no idea he had a gun.
I dive head first into the car,
slamming my head accidentally into the steering wheel.
Mashita tumbles into the passenger's
seat last.
He didn't tell me he had a gun.
Why would I tell you? No time to talk now.
Just hit the gas.
I'm trying!
Engine won't start.
Shit, shit.
Oh, oh man, what are you doing?
Mashita looks through the front windshield
at the figure approaching.
Hurry it up, he's coming!
Shoot, shoot, shoot!
Shoot the fucking shit!
Shoot, shoot it!
Shoot the fucking thing!
Wait, Christy cowards in the back seat
her head and her hands.
He's gone.
Something bombed the hood of the car,
the whole vehicle rocked violently.
Then...
it turned on.
Go, let's get the hell out of here!
Tire squealing, we race out of the parking lot.
An unspeakable sense of relief
fills the car.
If feeling truly alive
is a real sensation,
then it most definitely feels like this.
Where sees Toyota did it?
My car would never,
unless it's winter,
would never not start.
The greatest irony is that the only time
you can feel truly alive
is when you have a brush with death.
No one speaks for a while,
we're all soaking in that feeling.
Why is it more cooperative in winter?
It's uncooperative in winter,
so...
So it can
have trouble starting in winter
and you have to probably jump start it.
Yeah.
It's just a problem for everyone.
It's only after we've left the mountain
and reached buildings again that I feel like talking.
Still,
I glance through the rear view mirror
and then at the passenger seat,
both Maschita and Sho are looking out their windows.
Is it really okay for you to come here?
Mary finds out.
Obviously I came with her permission.
Maschita immediately retorts.
If I hadn't,
I wouldn't have come.
I get it.
Mary must have also guessed that we were in danger.
So,
what happened to that ex...
So what happened to that explanation?
Who's that woman behind us?
Alright.
I tell him everything I know so far
about Christy Adimura.
She offers up some details as well.
The moment her background comes to light,
Maschita smiles coldly.
Adimura?
Right now that you mentioned it,
I do remember you.
Oh yeah.
Thank goodness Maschita was there
and thank goodness he has a gun!
We're fired over that scandal.
Why? I never...
Can I be disgusted or amazed at his rudeness?
But these scars you...
But these scars you all had.
What are they called?
Marks.
Thanks. So, all of you have these marks.
What happens when you have one?
Well...
Maschita butts in from the passenger seat.
You die within a few days time.
Suffering from something like amnesia.
You zone out. Your brain takes a vacation.
It all happened to me.
Show scoffs.
You talk like it's someone else's problem.
Maschita didn't mean it like that.
You can only be blunt when discussing this.
Doesn't look like show will buy that excuse though.
Yes. Yes, it's really not your problem.
After all, you don't have a mark anymore.
Oh. What's he talking about?
Oh, well, you see...
Maschita has already lost
Hanna Hiko's mark. He's free now.
So, there's no good reason for him
to be here with us, but...
You're putting yourself...
In danger for the truth?
I can't believe it. You're like a saint.
Wait.
You're putting yourself out there for the truth?
You're like a saint.
There you go.
Christie's exaggerated compliment
is drowned out by Maschita's sardonic laugh.
It's nothing that noble.
But thanks to that,
I've learned the thing I want...
I most wanted to know.
And what's that?
When and how people get that mark.
The first time I was oblivious,
but this time,
I was aware of it.
Does he have it again?
Maschita, you don't mean...
He gives me his usual crooked smile.
Grannon shows me his wrist.
Sure enough, his skin is blemished by a scar
that looks like a spirit's bite mark.
Show cries out a look of horror on his face.
Come on, no way.
Do you seriously do that?
Man, give it up already.
It's someone else's problem, right?
So just shut it.
After everything.
We did.
He's like, I got it again, just to see
how you get one.
Maschita, could I say something?
What's wrong?
Nothing's wrong.
You never told me you had a gun.
Oh, that.
He laughs scornfully
and shoves a paper bag into my hands.
I open the bag and find
a revolver-style handgun
at the bottom.
If you want it taken.
That's not why I
Maschita keeps on talking
without stopping to hear what I have to say.
It's loaded with five bullets.
You can hang on to it.
I promise.
I promise you what.
Don't use it on anything other than a spirit.
Not that there's any proof
it will work on them.
We got a gun!
We, I think, I think
our main character
and he should kiss. Yes, I believe so.
No.
Of course.
I have any experience with guns.
There's no way I would.
To be fair,
I really, I don't really know.
But at the very least, right now,
I'm not getting the feeling that I can handle a gun.
But, MC is Senpai.
Well, Senpai, alternate route, okay?
This is like, uh, what is it?
Alternate reality, okay?
We can write fan fiction!
Oh.
Only use it under extreme stress.
With no experience, you will hit your mark.
Well, whatever. If I'm there,
just leave the shooting to me.
You can face the spirit some other way.
Yeah, that's how
it was in elementary two.
And for God's sake,
keep it.
Gun possession gets you three years
penal labor.
I'll get hit with one
to ten myself just for giving it to you.
And shooting a single bullet
will get you more than three years,
if not a life sentence.
Damn, gun laws in Japan, huh?
Is that how you're telling me not to use it?
No, I'm telling you that if it's restricted
that badly by the law,
it's got that kind of power.
Got a handgun.
Mark?
This color grows more vivid.
A few hours left
till death closes in.
Welcome back,
Lord Darling.
At least I can save now, yeah.
And I think,
I think we're good.
I think we're good, Senpai.
That's a lot of excitement.
I think that's a good place to
to stop at. What do you think, Senpai?
You as well, Lord Cho.
It appears that the woman with you
is also a markbearer.
We introduce Christy
and then Mary.
Christy is to fill her in on everything.
Is this the first stream of this game?
Um, I have one more
one more
before this, where I kind of
yapped a lot more.
I yapped a whole lot.
A mark after your life.
Memory, loss,
and the spirits who curse them into the living.
Feels like a chapter just ended, right?
Christy accepts her new reality
surprisingly quickly. Guess it's only natural
after what she saw in the forest.
I then update Mary on what we found.
I see. What a close call
for you.
I can hear relief in her voice,
but why did she let Mashita go?
If you must know
after you left,
Lord Mashita insisted on traveling
to the forest as well.
Her eyes look over to Mashita.
I'm not
I'm not one to just sit around.
Mashita shrugs nonchalantly.
But there, yeah, though
there are one before this was mostly
me yapping and doing a bit
of the first chapter. We finished
the first chapter
in the stream and then we started the second
chapter. So we're still kind
of in the beginning of it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm glad everyone's enjoying
this. I thought at first people would
find this kind of boring, but
but I'm glad that everyone's
like enjoying it now.
It was it was quite the issue.
A selfish attitude like that could
get all of you, Mark Barris killed.
I normally
would have refused.
Did something
happen? No.
I admit I had a foreboding
feeling. I sense danger
was closing in on you, Lord
Darling. So he went
an emergency measure.
Lord Mashita
please know I will not allow
such a thing a second time.
Her cool voice is spicier
than you. Mashita's
so hard headed. I wonder if she's actually getting
through to him at all.
Now, from what you've told me
you are positive that it was
Chimio who gave Lord Cho his mark.
Yeah, yeah
that ugly monster is definitely the
huge man I saw that time.
The fact that I have the mark
now to prove it.
Mashita rubs at its wrists
smirking.
So, what exactly
are you planning? Don't tell
me you're seriously thinking of fighting that thing.
There's no way you'd win.
You're completely mad if you think you can.
She's right. A certain someone awesome.
Someone's awesome bullet didn't
even scratch it. We need
a tank or something to beat that thing.
The room fall silent.
I'm sure all of us are thinking about what
we saw back at the forest.
I feel so bad for
Kimura.
There's no way we can do anything
about a monster like that.
You have to leave it to the police.
You honestly believe they'll do something.
Go
and make a suicide pack
with that naive thinking.
Believe me out of it.
What? How dare you?
No boss.
This is all high and mighty talk
coming from you? That mean
you got an idea how to beat it?
How the hell would
I know that?
When I'm willing to risk my life to find one.
The shout is
horse. Probably uneasy.
Christy shivers.
So it just glares up Machita.
Not where silence falls again.
What are the police going to do?
The police will just be like
yeah sure whatever.
Or die like the
the freaking
do you remember the
the guard?
Yeah probably not.
We're wasting
time. And Machita
is the police.
We've got to do something
but
What do we do
Senpai? Do we just
turn to Mary?
I'll turn to Mary. I'll be like
Take charge?
I don't know. I need more information.
You want to wear the pants
and take charge or let Mary handle it?
Well I want Mary's opinion.
Pull time? Be dummy?
No I don't want
We beat a ghost already. Okay
True.
Maybe she can give us more hints.
I thought Mary could give us more
hints.
Show to us we're awesome.
Has he been wrong yet?
Being too reliant
will make us look weak. Okay fine.
Fine. Fine.
I saw majority B1 anyways.
Fine. Fine. We take charge.
Fuck it.
We need to force everyone into action.
You can think about what we need to do
while we're walking around.
Of course.
We need to take charge.
We're walking around.
Going back to the forest.
I want to learn more about Shemeal.
I could use some help.
You say that but
no way we can find a needle in a haystack.
Pants equipped.
We gotta have a clue first.
Then why don't we check out the B farm
that's north of H tribe?
My reports say several people have seen
Shemeal there.
Hardly anyone ever goes there now
with the weird events in the forest.
Why is a B farm up there?
A cult called Honey B Family
used to live on the land.
Oh my gosh! A cult!
No one's there though.
No one's there anymore though.
How come?
They
committed mass suicide.
Mass suicide in the woods.
I've heard about it somewhere.
It's always a cult, huh?
I should have mentioned something similar
before we entered the forest.
Shemeal is obviously a member.
Maybe the leader, perhaps?
Tabloids and gossip shows ate it
up five years ago.
I've never reviewed the details though,
so the public doesn't know.
Oh yeah, I remember that.
But my club took up all my time
back then, so I don't know much.
You seem to know quite a bit about the forest,
Christie Ari Mora.
Read up on it to find a Primo spot.
Don't be an ass.
I was put in charge of the report,
and the search.
Honeybee Family was very
insular and secretive.
I heard the mass suicide in
was all the members following their leader.
Nudes channels chalked it up
to their discontent with modern society.
What happened to the leader?
Rumors say it was also suicide.
Though, I saw an old picture of him in.
He was a huge,
obese man. It's him! It's him!
I called it!
Suddenly, everyone is holding their breath.
No doubt, we're picturing the same thing.
The monster at the forest entrance.
A dead guy's come back to life?
We want to go to a place
with a zombie? That's totally insane!
It's just like the rumors.
It's just like the rumors say that forest
is correct. There's no way I could
just standing there, the voices
of suicide victims surrounded me.
Shut the hell up, Hank!
No more words out of those
lip flaps!
Oh!
Why is he like this?
Rude.
But now it's not
only the forest thus cursed.
I failed to kill myself and now I'm in
this mansion. I'm cursed too.
And so all of
her mutters have a dark edge.
Shimeo is somehow connected to
Honey Bee family, and the key
to destroying his grudge is going to be there.
Alright, what are you going to do, old lady?
You still want to die?
I'm considering it.
Hahaha.
But I'll help you guys
while I settle on my decision.
I'll pass on monster fighting.
Well, you'll help. I'm shocked.
If you leave your mark alone,
you won't need to hike back out there.
Oh, I hate owning strangers.
Especially pushy guys like you.
He seems grateful that we saved her.
There's no reason to refuse her help.
We need as much as we can get.
She is pretty sane though.
Why is everyone in this game so negative?
Well, everyone's about to die.
You know, I think that's a pretty good reason.
Hahaha.
Lady Christy said Shimeo
was often seen near the bee farm.
It may hold a connection to him.
Good luck.
New info was added to the spirit file.
Temporary retreat.
Let's save some pie.
They do be having death hanging over their heads.
I can't remember how, but...
No, wait. Hold on.
How do I exit this? Any...
Hack it.
Hack it. I think it was...
X? No.
Y?
Yeah, here it is.
We got it!
If we turn to Tito's screen,
all unsaved progress will be lost.
We saved already, so we're good.
Yay!
How was that, Senpai?
Are you enjoying the game now?
Hold on. Let me move myself. There we go.
Did you enjoy the game now?
And my chat box is broken.
Man.
Really fun, right? I'm so glad.
I know that it's kind of slow
to start.
Because I know when I started,
I ended up yapping a lot.
But it really ramps up, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I'm glad that everyone's enjoying it.
So I hope...
Oh, and there's a sequel to this game, too.
So maybe we can
play the sequel
after we finish this one.
What do you think?
Oh my gosh, the Brooklyn Dacons!
Let's go!
The sequel, yeah, it's called...
Okay, so the series is called
Spirit Hunter.
This one is Deathmark.
The sequel is called No Good.
NG. Spirit Hunter...
Is it Spirit Hunter?
Shit.
Hold on.
Deathmark.
Spirit Hunter, yeah.
Spirit Hunter, the second game is called
Spirit Hunter NG.
No Good!
And there's going to be
another...
another one.
Another one following that.
That is releasing...
No.
It released already, right?
Spirit Hunter Deathmark 2.
Did it release already?
Tenpais, I don't remember.
I think it's already out, I think.
Okay, yeah.
There's another one that comes out.
Yeah.
Do you know when Deathmark came out?
Let me check.
It came out in both
English and Japanese
in April 2019.
It was apparent...
It was real 2019.
It was this one.
The second one came out in
2022, yeah.
And the latest one,
Deathmark...
Spirit Hunter Deathmark 2
came out
February 15, 2024.
Yeah.
So, uh...
Yeah,
they had to go into the
banger title.
So the game is practically
brand new, yeah.
I actually bought it
when it just came out.
I bought the original
limited edition
because I saw it in stores.
I saw it at GameStop
and I was like, yeah!
This looks cool! I love visual novels!
And so I bought it
for a PS4.
And then I got lazy...
I got lazy
and I wanted to stream it
but I didn't want to plug in my PS4!
I didn't want to...
So I bought it again on Steam!
I double-purchased it
because I was too lazy to plug it in!
But yeah, it's because I really wanted to...
What's the word? I really wanted
to...
play...
play it, but I was like, oh, I'm too lazy.
I'll probably stop being lazy
and...
actually plug in
my...
um...
my systems?
My systems? Consoles?
Yeah, my consoles.
I bought it for PS4, yeah.
I don't... I don't have
the money
to pay for a PS5.
Actually, I was for a while
and I was like, why do I need a PS5?
And then now I'm just like, oh...
Well, it's kind of
backwards compatible, right?
Just say you're a super fan
and want to support the franchise even more.
Am I really a fan
if I never really played it to the end?
It's fine, the PS5 has no game.
Oh, but it's got like...
nice graphics.
Right?
It's got nice graphics.
And it's backwards and compatible,
so I thought that maybe
it would look prettier,
but I'm not sure
if it would look prettier at all...
at all for...
if it would make a difference,
you know, Senpai?
If I'm going to stream it through my PC,
I think it wouldn't
make that much of a difference, right?
At least, I don't think so.
Probably not, so that's why
in my mind I thought
um...
probably not, I probably...
I probably won't
won't get a PS5 yet.
It shouldn't be noticeable, yeah.
That's why I was like, okay, well,
if it's not going to improve the stream, I don't need it, right?
Everyone, PC is better.
Is your PC as strong as a PS5 though?
Yeah, PS5 isn't going anywhere
if you decide to want one later.
Yeah, I don't... they came out
of the slim, right?
Uh...
Came out the slim, which is slightly
cheaper, I think?
Um, right now, for my
PC, I'm using
uh...
an Xbox controller.
I have two Xbox controllers
and a PS4 controller,
a rose gold PS4 controller.
So, I don't know.
Um...
Yeah, I have the rose gold one.
I got it
when I was on sale.
Oh yeah,
Senpai, did you know that my first
home console was
a PS4?
My home... my first home console was a PS4.
Yeah, I think I told some Senpai's
earlier.
Yeah, like in a different stream.
I don't remember which stream, but I said...
My first console was a...
was a PS4.
Only handhelds before?
Yeah, my first handheld was
a DS... DS Lite, actually.
And then,
my second one
was...
a Vita?
Like a PS Vita?
And then...
And then I got a PSP,
finally.
Because it was on sale, because
PS Vita came out.
And then...
Honestly,
the Vita was so good, that thing never
died on me. That thing never died.
I left it for months, and it still had
70% batteries. Holy shit.
That was really good. That thing was good.
I have the...
the first gen of the PS Vita,
so it's super good.
It's got the beautiful screen.
They updated the screen to be
a lower quality, so it's had a lower price.
But like the first one? Yeah, the OLED.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I have that one.
That was my second one, because
it came out, and
I saw the color, it was white,
and I was like, oh, pretty!
That's why I got it!
So I got it, and I thought it was so nice.
It came with, um...
Assassin's Creed Liberation, I think.
It's also great
when you connect it to the PS4,
because it acts like another screen
and another controller. It's really great.
I don't know, I loved it. I loved it a lot.
I feel bad that it didn't take off.
She showed us a picture one day.
Yeah, I have, um...
I have some systems,
but now a friend of mine,
like one of my gal pals,
was decluttering.
And she was like,
hey,
you're streaming now, right?
And I said, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm streaming now.
I'm doing streaming stuff.
And she was like, I have
all these old consoles.
I don't need this anymore.
Do you want them? And so I inherited
her entire collection.
And I'm super thankful.
So I got
basically every console
basically
every console now.
Are you planning to get a 3DS
capture card for SMT4?
I don't know.
The guy who did like
DS capture stuff
doesn't make them anymore, right?
Sounds like a real homie.
I hope she gets good things in life. Yeah!
Is Mercy going to be a
retro slash nostalgia streamer then?
I'm hoping
I can play some games.
I ordered a retro tank.
Thank you, Senpai,
who crowdfunded that.
Thank you so much.
I ordered the retro tank already,
so it should arrive.
It's still kind of like processing,
but when it arrives,
I really want
to play.
I really want to play
on the Wii.
On the Wii.
No more heroes,
so I can use
the Wii remote.
It has the speaker.
I heard you can use it as
like a phone.
And you can hear the voices
go through the Wii
remote speaker. And I think that's real cool.
I think that's really cool.
So, that's something
I want to play. I also have
a bunch of PS2 games that
I want to play as well.
And I think it would be just really
fun.
And so
I thought this...
I googled it to see how I can capture
capture the
the consoles without
like too much equipment.
And so I found the retro tank
and then I was like, oh, it's
kind of expensive.
Maybe I'll put it on my list and maybe
we can crowdfund it together so
I can give more stuff
to show more stuff
to
to senpais. And I would be able to play
things on original hardware.
So I would love that.
I would love to do that.
So, yeah.
The Wii is retro?
How old is the Wii? It should be retro, right?
The Wii came out in 2006,
Senpai.
That's like...
I forget what year it is.
What year is it? 2024.
I can't math.
It's 18 years old.
It's legal.
It's an adult now.
Okay, Senpai.
Why did you bait yourself
into doing math, Mercy? It's because
I want to prove that it's...
I hate math,
but I want to prove that it's
uh...
It's uh...
It's old.
So...
Wii is officially legal. Like as an adult
it's officially like a legal adult, right?
Um...
Yeah, so I would love to play like
PS2 games.
And...
I also have like an Xbox.
I think it's the 360?
Anyways, I have like so many,
so many like consoles now.
I have like SNES.
I don't think I have a Genesis though.
I have to check.
Wait, or maybe I do.
Oh well, I have like so many.
I have so many like consoles now
and I would love to play.
Just this collection after all.
It's um...
It's uh...
Like my friend gave it to me, right?
Like she gave it to me.
That's so nice!
So that's why I'm just like
well...
It was so kind.
She was so kind enough
to give it to me, so I should probably
you know...
I should probably
play it, right?
Like I have so many games now.
Like so many!
SNES threatening in some way.
What do you mean?
Damn, is your friend single?
I'm pie.
I'm pie. Please only look at me.
Please only look at me, Senpai.
I would greatly appreciate you
not...
not moving your eyes
to someone else.
Okay?
I think you need
some time alone in a barrel.
Six feet under.
Oh, they get a breathing tube at least?
No.
I'm about to play
all these nice games
for Senpais.
And this is how you treat me?
Damn!
Anyways...
Senpais, ignoring that Senpai.
Um...
I think it'll be great
to play like all these games.
I want to go through
my collection of games
before I
go through
any...
any other...
any other newer games.
Unless...
you know, SMT
Vengeance
looking pretty nice right now.
But I don't want to play it.
I have to play the
first one,
the SMT 5,
which gives me motion sickness, so I have to take my pills
or something.
Vengeance is out. I know!
I see all these, like,
screenshots and I'm like,
it's looking kind of...
It's looking really great. It looks really great.
Vengeance is basically 5,
but better. I mean...
Uh, yeah, it's...
Does Minecraft activate your motion sickness?
Yeah, it does.
Like, anything kind of first person
often
activates the
the motion sickness. And you know what?
What is also?
Um...
It's not a sequel to 5,
just an updated version? Seriously?
I thought it was a sequel
because it's...
because it's Apocalypse, right? So...
SMT 4
Apocalypse was a completely different cast.
It's like a completely different cast.
Like, you play as a completely different character
and everything.
It's like Persona 5 Royale
is an updated
P5. Seriously?
Um...
But I thought it said
Apocalypse with it!
But the subtitle
was also like Apocalypse
and I thought all of the sequels
were like Apocalypse.
Vengeance is just an update?
Huh...
Because like,
SMT 5 made me, like, throw up.
Made me throw up.
And another game that
surprisingly also makes me throw up is Sonic.
And all Sonic games also
has like...
has like, lots of motion
and like, screen shakes
that I was like...
So there's a lot of games that makes me go
ugh...
So can you do FPS?
Uh...
First person shooter?
First person?
So yeah, that's probably...
something that makes me going
ugh...
Mercy throwing upstream?
Well, at least throwing up is allowed on YouTube.
On...
on Twitch, you would be banned for that.
They banned it!
Against TOS?
Yeah, only third person games, realistically.
Um, Strani did say
I should expand my gaming repertoire.
So...
I'm willing to try
basically all games.
Twitch bans you for getting sick?
Um, and you...
It's because...
I believe it's because...
Okay, okay.
This is like a story that I think I heard.
This is the reason why, but I could be wrong.
But I remember it's because
someone was
doing some kind of fetish thing
where they were throwing up.
And it was like, pretty dangerous.
And it was encouraging, like, you know...
Um...
Like, it was like...
doing some fetish thing
where people were paying them
to throw up.
So...
to take action against that,
um...
Twitch was like, okay, you cannot throw
up on stream then.
Ahem.
Hey, Mercy, if you were chill
with all visual novels out,
it would be fine too. Um...
Mostly it was like the point-and-click stuff.
She was like, I need you to...
I need you to try more games.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, I can do that.
I can do that.
Is this like the girl
bottling her farts and getting sick?
Probably.
I don't know.
Would you play
other games like SMT Devil Survivor
or Fire Emblem?
I don't like Devil Survivor.
I played it on the DS. I have it for the DS.
I just don't like the gameplay mechanic
of it.
I did like, uh, what's the one again
where they have all the massive stuff?
I don't know, what was the call again?
Uh...
Strange Journey.
Yes, I like Strange Journey though.
I like Strange Journey.
And I did like what I played
for the PS2
of what I played.
Did you know Devil Saga
was good too?
Uh...
Strange Journey or Archie and Noah
are redux. I liked
both, but I own redux
and I had to borrow from a friend
the original Strange Journey.
Um...
I didn't like the
the gameplay mechanics of
of, uh...
uh...
Devil Survivor though. I didn't like that one.
I just, I know, I know it's like
people were like, oh well, whatever.
I just didn't like the like tiles.
I didn't like it.
So, that's why I was kind of like
ehh, no, no thanks.
Uh, it felt like
a tactics game and like a,
you know, like one of those chess tactic games
or like...
Uh, like, I'm gonna get,
I'm gonna get fricking fried for this,
but I'm not a huge fan of Fire Emblem
because of like, its chess
like, tile mechanics.
Because I was like, uh...
I don't know.
Kind of boring.
It was kind of boring.
I mean, maybe I'll give it another go,
but when I played it,
I didn't like it.
Like, uh...
I also, I remember trying to stream
um...
Fire Emblem, which one is it? Three Houses?
And I just could not
make it entertaining.
I just could not make it entertaining.
I mean, I tried.
Really hard.
So, yeah.
I just didn't like the tiles.
I was like, uh...
Maybe...
Maybe I can try it again later,
but...
I don't think
I like that type of gameplay.
But yeah, I do like SMT though,
like SMT games as a whole.
I do have... Oh, I do have...
I did like, um...
I did like...
Devil Summoner.
That one was good.
I like that one.
You take Strange Journey.
Do you... Do you like Soul Hackers?
Hold on, give me a minute.
I never played Soul Hackers, actually.
That's the only one I didn't...
That's the only one I didn't play.
I didn't get to play Soul Hackers.
That was the only one I didn't...
I didn't play.
I was never able to find it.
I know the second one,
the Hackers 2 that came out recently,
has very mixed reviews,
and it makes me
hesitant to even pick it up,
you know?
I think another game I would love to play
are the Atelier games.
So, I'd love to play, like...
Atelier.
I know... I know...
My first Atelier game is not exactly like
one that...
Uh...
That people are like,
oh, that's not... That's the one that...
That you... You like?
So, the one that I liked
and the one that I played,
the most of that I really enjoyed
was Liddy and Soule.
I don't know, I thought it was cute?
I thought it was super cute,
and I thought it was, like, great.
And then I wanted to play,
like, Sophie and stuff,
but I just never had the time to,
and then I played a bit of Ryza,
and I was like, oh, yeah, this is great.
I played, um...
But then I just didn't have time to pick it up again.
I bought the Ryza books, though,
and I loved the art by Noko.
Noko did a great job
on all the arts, because I think
they're a great artist.
Um...
I played...
Atelier...
Rorona, I think?
Rorona?
Not Rorona, sorry.
Which one is the one with the pink-haired
daughter... daughter one?
What's the list of it?
Not Meridu.
It's, like, the one
that's, like, one of them's a kid.
Uh...
Shit, what's it called?
The kid?
I think? Is it Meridu?
It's kind of new-ish.
No, it's not Meridu.
Hold on.
List of...
Atelier games?
Atelier games? Thank you.
Uh...
This one!
Atelier Lulua!
I hated Lulua!
It was cheap! I was like...
I feel like I'm playing a stupid phone game!
What the fuck?
I know what her keyboard sounds
is so immaculate.
Oh yeah, my keyboard, it's, um...
red switches
so they don't make that much noise.
Sorry, Senpai.
But, like,
Atelier Lulua was shit garbage.
I was like, I feel like I'm playing a stupid phone game.
It was, it wasn't interactive.
It was no fun.
I feel like it was rushed.
It was not good.
Like, it looks cute. Like, it looks cute
as fuck, right?
Like...
The design is, uh...
is, it's cute.
I thought it would be, like,
Liddy and Sue
and it just wasn't there.
It just wasn't there.
And I was playing Lulua and I was like,
oh fuck, this sucks.
This really fucking sucks.
Uh...
And so I just
didn't want to play
Lulua.
After, like, the getting out of the town,
I was like, and playing a little bit
in the area, I was like, this fucking sucks.
So, I didn't enjoy it,
but I hear Riza is so much better
and I played a bit of Riza and I think
I think I enjoyed it.
I really think I did enjoy
Riza.
Uh, but, like, Lulua sucked.
Uh, Riza.
And I would love to play, like, Riza 2
and Riza 3. I have Riza on
PS4, so I'll have to plug that in
again. I, I, I'm kind of like,
I don't, I kind of don't
want to, uh, buy
more games.
So, yeah, but otherwise,
yeah, those are some games that I'm
kind of like, yeah, I kind of want to play those,
but I'm also
a little hesitant because it's
grindy and
I don't know, sometimes we'll be bored if
I grind it a lot.
Any JRPGs you want to play on stream,
like Dragon Quest? Uh...
What was the, what was the western RPG
that I was playing that I was
saying before? Wild Arms!
I play Wild Arms.
And...
Uh...
I don't know, other ones.
I have to look through my collection again.
Um...
Neptunia?
Oh gosh, Neptunia games suck.
It's hot
garbage.
I look, I look at...
I go
to the
store.
The, the, the, the
the worker was
like...
was like, oh, Neptunia?
Are, are these game, I was
meaning to get into it. Are these games good?
I go, no, it fucking sucks. Don't even bother.
Pay them, pay them
their money and go
leave with my Neptunia game.
And they fucky. And I'm just like, I fucking
hate this game, but it's so cute.
Dimes are so cute.
Like, honestly, hot garbage
shit gameplay, really great
design, really great characters.
I'm just like...
It's garbage.
Absolutely garbage. Every time,
every time I, I play another
Neptunia game, I'm just like, please
let it be good. And it's not.
I fucking hate it.
Fucking hate it.
I literally was like
literally the cash register guy
was like, oh yeah, I've been meaning to get into
the series. Is it any good? No.
Leaves.
But yeah, um,
I think I'll play Neptunia. I think all I
would do would be like, I hate
this.
All I would say
is that I would hate this.
Would you ever play the world end with you
on your DS Lite?
Uh, I would, but
I don't have anything to capture
DS with. So you'd need
like, uh, completely new DS
with a capture system
on it. And I just don't have that. And the guy
who used to make them, don't make them anymore.
So, uh, yeah, we're shit
out of luck, guys.
And I am not allowed to do anything else
other than play on original hardware stuff.
Any PS2 games
that you're looking forward to streaming soon?
Definitely.
Probably digital
Devil Saga
and Devil Summoner. Yeah, those two
are definitely like my main ones that I'm just like, yeah,
I'll be great.
Ah, DS Lite
Hand Cam Stream. That's not going to
work out senpai because I
I can get like button
mashing and it would just shake all the time.
So you wouldn't even be able to see
what is going on, right? And then I
turn
the DS and go
and it's not going to capture, right?
You know what I mean? Like handheld.
It's like you're you're supposed to turn
and go
go
You wouldn't happen to know Legend of
Legia, would you, Mercy?
Legend of Legia?
Legend of
Legia.
I might have to see it.
I do not know this game.
Well, it looks pretty cool.
I don't even know if I have it though.
I might have it. I have to look.
I have to look at it, but
I definitely want to play with like
if I could somehow
Excuse me.
Too much. Not enough liquid.
If I could
capture it somehow
for senpai while still be able
to use the stylus and everything because
let me tell you
it was really hard to play games.
DS games without
using the stylus.
You know, Legend of Legia, my nuts
asshole
Anyways
But yeah, I love using
the stylus. I'm not going to lie.
I love using the stylus so
playing any DS games without
using the stylus would fucking suck.
Forget, do you like rhythm games?
No.
I suck at rhythm. I have no sense of rhythm.
Thank you, Jamie, for the
for the
most tier, for sending off the most
tier. Thank you.
For being a member.
Most tier and membership is still the same, right?
Yeah, yeah.
It should be the same. Thank you for being a member.
I wonder if you do the Yakuza series. I do have some
Yakuza games, so
Maybe
I had fun, but most of the time
I know
I know that
I'm going to just
play the claw game over
and over.
I'll play the claw game over and over.
I'll be like, check this out, Senpai.
Yeah.
Look at me. I'm
winning.
Yeah, winning prizes for Senpai.
Go to karaoke.
I suck at karaoke, by the way.
I suck at the karaoke because it's like
I'm not familiar
because I always get confused about which
controller I'm using. So when it's like
press the buttons and the rhythm
and I'm like, oh shit, which buttons which
Honestly, I went to
the
when I was playing Yakuza Zero, I went to the
the video club a lot.
The video store a lot.
I
Me too for completion rewards, right?
Yeah, completion rewards.
Get that a hundred percent.
Oh
man, I'm still yapping.
I'm still yapping.
I want to play lots of games with Senpai
and I know it's like
oh
I feel bad though
because
all I've been playing have been games
and I've been like
oh yeah, I want to schedule this game
and this game and then I'm like
I should probably schedule in some other
stuff too.
Are you planning to do another karaoke stream?
Yeah.
I don't know when
but yeah.
I've been like, oh my gosh, I want to play this game
this game and this game and this game
other stuff, yeah, like ASMR
maybe like
I don't know like
hand cam streams
uh
batsu wheel or something like that
but me I was like a game, game, game, game
game, game, game, game, game, game, game
like I was like maybe I should do
do those things
and I'm just like
but this game, I want to play this game
with Senpai
Senpai, help me, this part is hard
speaking of hand cam streams
how did the alchemy come out?
It's super cute!
It's unlike my makeup
it's not like my makeup
uh
container thing
oh well
it's on that right now
so that's why I was like
uh okay
honestly I'm just like uh
hand cam ASMR
um I'm not sure if I can
knew that I feel like
I feel like it's you know
it's just super awkward
since I'm very unfamiliar
with ASMR
and I'm still learning
I would be like just me
just need my hands just go like
ugh
shrugging every moment
like I don't know what I'm doing
I'm just doing what I think
would sound nice
honestly like
I bought some things and I was like
um
I think this would sound nice on a microphone
on like the 3D
oh I think it would sound nice
gives us, gives you a thumbs up
yeah
so I feel so awkward
when I do like ASMR
I mean like
I think
I kind of face palm on myself
when people are like do ear copying
and then I was like
the 3D all ears with your hands
and I said okay
and then I had to ask
10 pies, now what
ah
I didn't know what copying was
like I was researching
stuff and then I was like
I don't know everything
so yeah I feel a little
embarrassed about that
But yeah, otherwise it's um, yeah, I think it's fun, it's also fun.
The giggles were the best part, I think Senpai is making me laugh and then it's really hard
to not laugh when you're trying to not laugh and then it becomes like it's you laugh harder.
Oh yeah, just try, try trying to laugh quietly or trying to not laugh and then you end up
laughing, you know, and then you keep on laughing and you can't stop.
So yeah, that is the giggle, yeah, the giggle feedback loop, exactly.
So yeah, oh speaking of Senpai, um, did you see my new ASMR video?
Kind of, it's kind of like a jokie ASMR video.
You did?
Yeah.
Did you know?
My laughing?
I didn't stop laughing, it was straight up.
I laughed for, I couldn't get past, I laughed, I laughed non-stop, that was one take, yeah.
You know what else is also one take?
That's surprising?
My cover song, the like, notice me Senpai cover song was also one take.
Because I will tell you why.
People were like, oh, why didn't you do it in parts and I was like, listen, that song
is kind of bad, I'm not going to lie to you, um, that song is kind of bad, so if I don't
do it in one take, I'm going to lose the rhythm really fast.
So I, like, when I tried it in parts, I was like, I cannot, I cannot do this in more than
one part because it's going to lose, I'm going to just be like, da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-
different like that's that's the that's the beat right it's hard it's hard to follow that
it's hard to follow that so I was like I have to do it in one shot
hey yo why are you clapping to the beat of the song and pie I saw you at school today took
your picture then I walked no then I snapped away I want you to notice me but I'm just someone
you don't notice still I think I've got another rival I have to kill right you see you see where
I'm just like okay this is not this is having I'm having problems here please notice me some pie
please notice me some pie right and then I messed up a bunch of times honestly but but
editors be editing you know luckily like it it's it's hard if when I did the song it was
some pie I saw you at school today took your picture then I snuck away I want you to notice me
but you're just someone I'm just someone you don't notice fuck it's really hard it's really hard
okay so it's it's a song it's definitely a song you cannot sing in parts you should share the
unedited version someday the unedited version only has one mistake it only has one mistake and
the mistake is an please notice me one please notice me some pie that was easily edited and
the only reason why that was a mistake was because I ran out of breath one please notice me some
pie and it was just like please notice me some pie and that was it breathing breathing
specs again that cup sounded real about Calif was real I was easily edited out because well I
say like please notice me some pie like a million times right like so many times just replace one
it's fine like that was the only mistake I had and I think I lost the beat a little bit towards
the end cuz I was like okay I hate this song like I originally I actually asked cuz I was like
I'm supposed to cover this and I know I know it's like a song that people like but I honestly do
not like the song personally because it just doesn't sound good to me then again I am also not a
music person and as you all know that I am I don't really listen to music senpai senpai so I don't
listen to music so I'm kind of insane I'm kind of insane it's probably yeah it's probably just
something simple like it's not enough melody or something it turned out well man yeah I'm glad it
turned out well because I was like oh no music at all yeah like when I'm studying or focused I
don't listen to music like at all the only times I ever listen to music is kind of like if I want
something atmospheric then it's like a gay molestee or anime song really no song when though I would
love to I would love to release some of my original songs yeah you listen to Amiens or
white noise or not listen to things why you work I don't listen to anything at all why I work senpai
like honestly I do not listen to any music it is silent why I'm working I cannot have anything
interrupt me why I think like otherwise I get too distracted or it's just I don't like it
like I just don't like it I just need my moment to to be in my head and just write it
but like most people will just call me insane and they're right I am definitely not someone
um that's not normal I know that's not normal so that's why people are like yeah you're kind of
insane and I'm like yeah you're right you're right that is insane behavior but I don't know it's just
something I've been like doing most of my life like if I need total silence okay this is
this is going to be very funny but when I was in college I would sometimes if I wanted total
deafening silence I would work in the bathroom I would study in the bathroom because it was quiet
there was nothing yeah it was just like you know the echoing or like whatever like the
complete silence in the bathroom was just I just studied there
but the germs it's my germs like at home at home not like in the school bathroom I meant at
home I would study in the bathroom like in the tub because I could just focus there
okay if you top has plenty of space and like I would actually bring in a table I would bring
in a table and then I would just work in silence because it was like away from everything there
was nothing distracting me I would just I just work and it it was really productive
it was a tub full full of what it's just me it's just me I'll just sit in there or I'll sit on
I'll put down the toilet seat like cover and then I would just put the table and just start studying
not soaking in the water no it's like empty empty you know whatever gets you to pass
I got pretty good grade senpai so don't worry don't worry senpai I got good grades
so yeah I would just work in the bathroom and just study and write notes in the bathroom
because there was nothing distracting me and the bathroom has like white walls so it felt
kind of sterile too so I was like okay yeah it's just peaceful here I can study here
because if I'm in my if I'm in my bedroom and I'm just like oh I have so many toys to play with
how do I get this kind of power like studying power I don't know
toys yeah like you know my ds is there or the tv is there and and uh look my vita oh my gosh look
there's new shows ah
oh my gosh books mangos mangos yeah I can't think when it's too quiet how'd you get the opposite
honestly using a tv as a toy is crazy really I don't know I feel like technology is like a
sort of toy for everyone right that's why I call it a toy um
honestly how I got to study was I guess
I didn't have anything else to think about
I I didn't have anything else to think about and deadlines really worried me and I had like
the crippling anxiety of failure so I was like no I can't do it I had I have to pass
and I don't know I also had uh
I had like a genuine interest in the subject as well
so uh if I I did much better in subjects I had an interest in of course
and other times I would be like uh no I'm oh I although I did quite well for subjects I
did had no interest in I still forced myself to be interested
so yeah uh honestly if anyone has like studying techniques or anything and they ask me I just
like uh work in the bathroom I don't know I I was I'm weird I'm a little weirdo
I'm a little weirdo and so yeah I I like honestly I genuinely like studying as well
so yeah mercy solution is simple don't have ADHD
yeah only have diet ADHD
but yeah I'm I'm a little bit strange I'm a little bit loopy I guess
but yeah I I I can hyper fixate on something real fast
so yeah
uh yeah studying tip for me probably really fucking useless
yeah
yeah that's why we like you is because I'm a I'm a little weirdo I'm a little freak
thanks senpai
I I I appreciate it
so
hold on
I want to see who's on
felt that I can grade into them I'm I'm I'm winding down senpai I'm winding down
so I'm feeling I'm feeling like I'm gonna wind down enjoy myself what do I have for my schedule
tomorrow right I have my collab with strawney tomorrow I I am going to be playing untitled goose
game and then I have a day off and then we have the uno collab and then another day off so
uh next week I'm going to probably have a very small schedule as well
um just so I can I can get like a lot of things done I still have a lot of a lot of chores and
I need some days to just relax by myself or relax with some friends as well so I
I need a few more days off to do chores and then also like have some time
so yeah uh that's my schedule coming up I am probably going to pick up some new games
next week so that uh we'll have a little bit of variety and then come back to other games
just so to like finish some games off uh I think I'm still pretty far in killer seven
like I'm still kind of in the beginning part with killer seven I'm not good at that game so
that one will probably be spaced apart as well and uh and I know I know I'm gonna pick up some
games so yeah did we finish harvester I passed out no we're I think I think I'm at the very last
ending of harvester I think I think we have at least one or two more hours of that game so I
I am hoping to finish it at least the week after next week yeah I want to finish harvester
so I'm pretty sure I have like an hour to two hours left
yeah we can harvest one more stream out of that game and then we close a chapter
in harvester and we pick up a new game like another new game
it really depends on like how I feel like some games I'm kind of trying out to just gauge like
how us tempis like them or not as well
the meat the wait we have to say with the the hard T at the end the meat
so yeah uh who's uh um
um
give me a second supplies
sort of streaming
or
oh that might be tough okay I think I know who to raid um everyone um so uh
be super nice to to the uh to I I think I'm gonna raid scion
uh from vnu uh so we're gonna see
who's going to be playing minecraft
so scream for mercy raid uh just be super nice everyone
just be super nice to to the person we're raiding because this is gonna be my first impression
of um my first impression I haven't actually talked to scion at all so be nice tempis uh
so I'm going to let you all go now so
so
good night senpais remember scream for mercy yeah
bye bye good night
you